The Source has headphones for everything. We have headphones for running, working, calling, cleaning, gaming, cooking, singing, fishing, hiking, drumming, dancing, lounging, weightlifting, painting, traveling, podcasting, dog walking and streaming TV shows. Yes, The Source has headphones for everything. Find amazing prices on headphones and earbuds from top brands like Beeps, Sony, Bose, Skullcandy and more at The Source, of course. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Dear Melanie. Hi. Hope all is well with you and thanks for the interesting mail you've sent in the last while. I've been busy in the garden wherever I can, getting it slowly in shape. We've had some really nice weather lately.
The Source 有各种各样的耳机。我们有跑步、工作、通话、打扫、游戏、做饭、唱歌、钓鱼、远足、打鼓、跳舞、休闲、举重、画画、旅行、播客、遛狗以及看电视流媒体用的耳机。没错，The Source 的耳机应有尽有。当然，您可以在 The Source 以惊人的价格买到来自 Beeps、Sony、Bose、Skullcandy 等顶级品牌的耳机和耳塞。我们的每期节目都涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机干预中心。有关获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本期节目简介。亲爱的梅兰妮。嗨。希望你一切都好，也谢谢你这段时间寄来的有趣信件。只要一有空，我一直在忙着打理花园，让它慢慢恢复原貌。我们最近的天气真的非常好。
I'm still getting harassed from time to time by someone trying to break in here, but I think we've come up with a solution if it doesn't cost too much. Gord is going to wire in a sensor for me, so hopefully we'll know when someone enters the backyard and we can quietly call the police while he is busy doing his thing. I'm really hopeful we might actually catch him soon. Wouldn't that be wonderful? I could actually start living a normal life again. I've almost forgotten what that feels like. The police have been pretty useless, so it would be wonderful to hand him over on a silver platter. Well, I must bathe and get ready for Marion to pick me up. Hope to hear from you soon. Love, Cindy. 38-year-old Cindy Makepeace was chainsmoking cameo menthol cigarettes at her dining room table. It was October 12, 1982, and she had just received her eighth threatening phone call in five days. During most calls, nothing could be heard on the other line other than heavy breathing.
我还是会时不时地遭到某个试图闯入这里的人的骚扰，但我认为我们已经想出了一个解决方案，只要花费不太高的话。戈德打算为我接通一个传感器，所以希望当有人进入后院时我们能知道，这样我们就可以在他忙于他的勾当的时候悄悄报警。我真的很希望我们能快点抓住他。那不是太棒了吗？我终于可以开始重新过上正常的生活了。我都快忘了那种感觉是什么样的了。警察一直没什么用，所以如果能用银盘子把他亲手奉上，那就太棒了。好了，我得去洗个澡，准备让马里昂来接我。希望能早日听到你的消息。爱你的，辛迪。38 岁的辛迪·梅克皮斯（Cindy Makepeace）正坐在餐桌旁一根接一根地抽着卡梅洛薄荷烟。那是 1982 年 10 月 12 日，她刚刚在五天内接到了第八个恐吓电话。在大多数电话中，听筒那边除了沉重的呼吸声什么也听不见。
Other times, a man spoke to her in a menacing whisper. He had made crude sexual suggestions to Cindy a few days prior, but she hung up in disgust before hearing him out. The most recent call had really unnerved her. The man warned, you're dead, Cindy. As night fell, Cindy went around her multi-level stuck-out home in Vancouver, Canada, closing the window drapes. Ten minutes later, the phone rang. The familiar, low-growing voice said, Don't think pulling the drapes means I don't know you're in there. Cindy called the police. An officer arrived and found no sign of the caller lurking outside the house. He couldn't do anything except suggest Cindy make a list of all the calls she received and to get an unlisted phone number. With no known enemies, the highly respected pediatric mental health nurse was at a loss as to who could be harassing her. One week later, Cindy returned home with friend Agnes Woodcock after a night out to find that someone had gained entry into her house.
而在其他时候，一个男人会用威胁性的耳语对她说话。几天前，他对辛迪说了一些粗俗的性暗示言语，但辛迪还没听完就厌恶地挂断了电话。最近的一次电话真的让她感到非常不安。那个男人警告说：“你死定了，辛迪。”夜幕降临，辛迪走遍了她位于加拿大温哥华的复式独立住宅，拉上了所有的窗户窗帘。十分钟后，电话响了。那个熟悉的、低沉的声音说道：“别以为拉上窗帘我就不知道你在里面。”辛迪报了警。一名警官赶到后，发现没有迹象表明有来电者在房屋外潜伏。他什么也做不了，只能建议辛迪列一份她接到所有电话的清单，并去申请一个未登记的电话号码。这位备受尊敬的小儿心理健康护士没有已知的仇家，她完全不知道是谁在骚扰她。一周后，辛迪和一个朋友阿格尼丝·伍德科克（Agnes Woodcock）外出归来，发现有人闯入了她的房子。
She raced next door and asked her neighbour, who was aware of the calls Cindy had been getting, to investigate. He entered the house ahead of Cindy and Agnes to make sure that the intruder was no longer inside. After a thorough search of all the rooms, the neighbour told the women that it was safe to go in. Cindy began to get ready for bed. A few minutes later, Agnes heard Cindy screaming. She found Cindy in her bedroom sobbing and clutching a pillow. The pillow, concealed under the covers of the bed, had been slashed to pieces. The cuts were precise and were carried out with a sharp object, like a razor. Constable Pat McBride of the Vancouver Police responded to Cindy's call. As nothing had been stolen from the house, McBride thought that someone was trying to send Cindy a message.
她跑向隔壁，请她的邻居去查看一下，这位邻居知道辛迪最近接到的那些电话。他走在辛迪和阿格尼丝前面进入屋内，以确保入侵者已经不在里面了。在对所有房间进行了彻底搜查后，邻居告诉两位女士可以放心进去了。辛迪开始准备睡觉。几分钟后，阿格尼丝听到辛迪发出尖叫声。她发现辛迪在卧室里泣不成声，紧紧抓着一个枕头。那个藏在床上的被子底下的枕头已经被划得粉碎。切口非常精准，是用类似剃须刀的锋利物品进行的。温哥华警察局的帕特·麦克布莱德（Pat McBride）警员接警来到了辛迪家。由于家里没有丢失任何东西，麦克布莱德认为有人在试图向辛迪传递某种信息。
Even though Cindy had changed her number, the threatening calls continued. They were mainly no-talk calls. Seeking comfort, Cindy contacted her husband. Cindy Hack had met psychiatrist Dr Roy Matepiece at Vancouver General Hospital in the fall of 1965. A natural beauty with long blonde hair, blue eyes and wide smile, Cindy would turn heads wherever she went. She quickly caught the attention of Roy, who was assisting Cindy with a group project for her nursing studies. The two became inseparable. In December 1966, Roy, who was 18 years older, left his wife and two children and married 22-year-old Cindy. The union was eventually accepted by Cindy's parents, Otto and Tilly Hack.
尽管辛迪已经换了号码，但威胁电话仍在继续。它们主要是无声电话。为了寻求安慰，辛迪联系了她的丈夫。辛迪·哈克（Cindy Hack）于 1965 年秋天在温哥华总医院遇到了精神病学家罗伊·梅特皮斯（Dr Roy Matepiece）博士。辛迪天生丽质，有着一头长长的金发、蓝色的眼睛和灿烂的笑容，无论走到哪里都会吸引人们的目光。她很快引起了罗伊的注意，当时罗伊正在协助辛迪完成一项护理学业的小组项目。两人变得形影不离。1966 年 12 月，大她 18 岁的罗伊离开了他当时的妻子和两个孩子，与 22 岁的辛迪结了婚。这段婚姻最终得到了辛迪父母奥托（Otto）和蒂利·哈克（Tilly Hack）的接受。
Roy soon became welcomed into the Hack family life, often playing cards and sharing a drink with Cindy's father, who was only six years his senior. The first few years of marriage were an extremely happy time for the newlyweds. Cindy, who always dreamed of working with children, was employed at the Children's Foundation, a job where she cared for children suffering from trauma and mental health conditions. In 1974, Cindy landed her dream job as the founding director for Blenheim House, a new centre for preschool children requiring mental health support. Described as gentle and kind, but firm when she needed to be, Cindy ran the centre with utmost professionalism and passion. In contrast, Roy Matepiece was not faring as well. Although a registered psychiatrist elsewhere, when Roy moved to British Columbia, he failed the accreditation process three times and was not permitted to practice psychiatry. Instead, Roy took a job as the head of medical services at BC Hydro, the British Columbian Electric Utility.
罗伊很快融入了哈克一家的生活，经常与只比他大六岁的辛迪的父亲一起打牌、喝一杯。结婚头几年，这对新婚夫妇过得非常幸福。辛迪一直梦想着从事儿童工作，她在儿童基金会（Children's Foundation）找到了一份工作，在那里她照顾那些遭受创伤和心理健康状况不佳的儿童。1974 年，辛迪得到了她梦寐以求的工作——担任布伦海姆之家（Blenheim House）的创始主任，这是一个为需要心理健康支持的学龄前儿童设立的新中心。辛迪被形容为温和善良，但在需要坚定的时候毫不含糊，她以极高的专业素养和热情运营着这个中心。相比之下，罗伊·梅特皮斯的情况则没有那么顺利。虽然他在其他地方是一名注册精神病学家，但当罗伊搬到不列颠哥伦比亚省时，他三次未通过资质认证程序，不被允许执业精神病学。相反，罗伊在不列颠哥伦比亚省电力公司（BC Hydro）担任医疗服务部负责人。
According to Cindy, the disappointment of failing the exams left Roy depressed and he became short-tempered and irritable. Roy was a keen sailor and fisherman. In 1977, he bought a 9-metre catamaran he named the Peacemaker. Cindy accompanied him on some of his voyages, but the trips were unpleasant as Cindy had a severe phobia of water. Her fear was so great that she couldn't even get into a swimming pool. When sailing in Roy's boat, Cindy would spend the majority of her time under the deck with her dog Heidi. Cindy's lack of interest in Roy's maritime activities drove a wedge between the couple. Cindy preferred tending to her garden, which became a sanctuary where she could escape her marital troubles. Cindy and Roy drifted apart over the years. On July 1, 1982, after 16 years of marriage, the couple separated amicably.
据辛迪所说，考试失败的打击让罗伊陷入了抑郁，他变得脾气暴躁、易怒。罗伊是一个热心的水手和渔夫。1977 年，他买了一艘 9 米的双体船，并将其命名为“和平缔造者”号（Peacemaker）。辛迪曾陪同他进行过几次航行，但这些旅行并不愉快，因为辛迪有严重的恐水症。她的恐惧是如此之大，以至于她甚至不敢进游泳池。在罗伊的船上航行时，辛迪大部分时间都会带着她的狗海蒂（Heidi）呆在甲板下面。辛迪对罗伊的海上活动缺乏兴趣，这在夫妻之间产生了一条鸿沟。辛迪更喜欢照料她的花园，那里成了一个避难所，让她可以逃避婚姻带来的烦恼。多年来，辛迪和罗伊渐行渐远。1982 年 7 月 1 日，在结婚 16 年后，两人友好分居。
They lived in different houses, but would continue to see each other for the occasional dinner date or trip to the symphony, a pastime they both enjoyed. Roy stayed in their home while Cindy rented the main floor of a house in East Vancouver, only 14 blocks from her workplace. Three months later, the harassing phone calls began. Sitting on Cindy's bed, Roy made peace, examined the slashed pillow. He tried to reassure Cindy, who was still very upset about the incident. As Roy left that evening, he took the pillow with him and threw it away. The following day, the tenants who rented the apartment underneath Cindy's phoned the local police. They knew Cindy had left for work, however, they could hear noises coming from her place above.
他们住在不同的房子里，但仍会见面共进偶尔的晚餐或去听交响乐，这是他们都喜欢的消遣方式。罗伊留在了他们的家中，而辛迪则在温哥华东部租下了一栋房子的底楼，距离她的工作地点只有 14 个街区。三个月后，骚扰电话开始了。罗伊·梅特皮斯坐在辛迪的床上，检查了那个被划破的枕头。他试图安慰辛迪，她对这起事件仍然感到非常难过。那天晚上罗伊离开时，他把枕头带走了并把它扔掉了。第二天，租住辛迪楼下公寓的租客给当地警察局打去了电话。他们知道辛迪已经去上班了，然而，他们能听到楼上她住所传来的噪音。
Officers arrived, but it appeared as though the intruder had come and gone without a trace. A few days later, Constable Pat McBride, who had been dispatched to Cindy's house on the night of the slashed pillow attack, returned to her home. To put her mind at ease, he had with him dead bolts to put on her doors. The two became good friends. McBride had separated from his wife and was looking to stay somewhere for a month while an apartment became available for him. Cindy suggested he rent a room in her house, explaining that it benefited them both. He would have somewhere to live and she would have someone to offer protection. Constable Pat McBride agreed and moved in on November 1.
警察赶到了，但看起来入侵者来去无踪，没有留下任何痕迹。几天前曾被派往辛迪家处理枕头被划破事件的帕特·麦克布莱德警员再次来到了她家。为了让她安心，他随身带了门栓，准备安装在她的门上。两人成了好朋友。麦克布莱德与妻子分居后，正在寻找一个地方住上一个月，直到有一套公寓空出来。辛迪建议他在自己家里租一个房间，并解释说这对双方都有好处。他有地方住，而她则有人提供保护。帕特·麦克布莱德警员同意了，并于 11 月 1 日搬了进去。
The no-talk telephone calls continued. On November 22, Cindy was getting into her car after a day of work when she noticed a note stuck to the windshield. An image of a woman who resembled Cindy had been cut from a magazine. Her eyes had been scratched out by a sharp object. Whoever was stalking Cindy Makepeace knew where she worked. Vancouver police increased their patrols around Cindy's house. On November 28, Officer Pat McBride returned to the property mid-shift to have a coffee with Cindy. After he left, he received a call out advising that Cindy's phone lines had been cut.
无声电话仍在继续。11 月 22 日，辛迪结束了一天的工作坐进车里时，发现挡风玻璃上贴着一张纸条。一个长相酷似辛迪的女人的图像被从杂志上剪了下来。她的眼睛被锋利的物体划掉了。无论谁在跟踪辛迪·梅克皮斯，都知道她在哪里工作。温哥华警方加强了对辛迪家周围的巡逻。11 月 28 日，帕特·麦克布莱德警员在执勤中途回到住所与辛迪喝咖啡。他离开后，接到了一通电话，被告知辛迪的电话线被切断了。
They had been cut in five places, however the phone line to the downstairs tenants remained intact. Cindy had received a hang-up call half an hour before she realized the lines were dead. Officer McBride and his partner kept surveillance on the home until their shift finished at 7am, but no further incidents occurred. He continued investigating, discovering that a woman two doors down from Cindy had also received hang-up and no-talk phone calls. A neighbour told Pat McBride that he had also seen a strange man lurking around Cindy's house on three occasions, but couldn't offer a description. In early December 1982, Officer McBride moved out of Cindy's house. Over the month that they had lived together, Cindy and Pat had formed a bond. The pair began dating before entering into an intimate relationship.
电话线在五个地方被切断了，然而通往楼下租客的电话线保持完好。在辛迪意识到电话线断了之前的半小时，她接到了一通挂断电话。麦克布莱德警员和他的搭档对这栋房子进行监视，直到早上 7 点换班，但没有发生进一步的事件。他继续进行调查，发现辛迪家隔了两户的一位女性也接到过挂断电话和无声电话。一位邻居告诉帕特·麦克布莱德，他曾三次看到一个陌生男子在辛迪家附近徘徊，但无法提供体貌特征。1982 年 12 月初，麦克布莱德警员搬出了辛迪的家。在他们同住的一个月里，辛迪和帕特建立了一种纽带。两人开始约会，随后确立了亲密关系。
At times they would double date with Roy Makepeace and one of his female friends. Even though she was living alone again, Cindy assured family and friends that she was fine. Cindy was resilient, she had endured hardships throughout her life and was not going to let the recent events get to her. Although loved by their parents, growing up, Cindy and her five siblings were disciplined sternly by their Air Force instructor father. At age six, Cindy began experiencing nightmares. They continued into her adult years and would cause her to wake screaming. Young Cindy's distress was amplified by her fear of the basement in her family home. Recalling her childhood to friends, Cindy remembered having to wait in the darkened space because there wasn't enough room for all the hack family around the dinner table.
有时他们会和罗伊·梅特皮斯以及他的一位女性朋友进行双人约会。尽管又开始独自生活，但辛迪向家人和朋友保证自己很好。辛迪很坚韧，她一生中经受过许多艰难困苦，不会让最近发生的事件打倒自己。虽然深爱着他们的父母，但在成长过程中，辛迪和她的五个兄弟姐妹受到了身为空军教官的父亲的严厉管教。6 岁时，辛迪开始做噩梦。噩梦一直持续到她的成年期，并会常常让她在尖叫中醒来。年幼的辛迪对家族住宅地下室的恐惧放大了她的痛苦。向朋友回忆童年时，辛迪记得自己不得不待在那个黑暗的空间里，因为餐桌周围没有足够的地方容纳所有的哈克家庭成员。
She was also sent down there for misbehaving. Cindy also confided to Roy that she had been sexually assaulted by one of her brothers as a child. Being someone who kept things to herself, she chose not to elaborate. Regular changes in postings for Otto meant that the hack family moved often, but Cindy maintained day grades throughout her schooling. She had dreams of attending college, however Otto was of the opinion that only his sons should attend. Instead, he permitted Cindy to enroll in nursing school. In 1963, Cindy met a resident doctor and the two of them had a brief relationship, ending when he was killed in an accident. Heartbroken, Cindy threw herself into her studies and became top of her class in the psychiatric components of her course.
她也曾因为淘气而被罚到下面去。辛迪还向罗伊吐露，她小时候曾遭到其中一个兄弟的性侵。由于她是一个把事情藏在心里的人，她选择不予详述。奥托频繁调动岗位意味着哈克一家经常搬家，但辛迪在整个求学期间一直保持着优异的成绩。她曾梦想上大学，然而奥托认为只有他的儿子们才应该上大学。相反，她被允许去注册护校。1963 年，辛迪遇到了一位住院医师，两人维持了一段短暂的恋情，直到他在一场事故中丧生而告终。心碎的辛迪将自己全身心投入到学业中，并在课程的精神病学部分取得了班级第一的成绩。
It was an area she found fascinating. In December 1982, police on heightened patrol noted Roy Makepeace's car circling the block of Cindy's residence. He drove into the laneway behind her house and turned the headlights off. Officers approached Roy, who claimed he was there to protect his wife. They advised him to move on. In the book about Cindy Makepeace by Ian Mulgrew, Cindy told Officer Pat McBride that one night she had awoken to a tapping at her window. Terrified, she pulled back the curtain to find Roy there, armed with a knife and a rifle. He told Cindy to sleep easy because he was guarding her premises. The next day, Roy recounted the night's events to Cindy, explaining his theory that someone from the mafia could be out to get her.
这是她觉得非常着迷的一个领域。1982 年 12 月，加强巡逻的警察注意到罗伊·梅特皮斯的车在辛迪住所所在的街区盘旋。他开进了她家后方的巷子里，并关掉了车头灯。警察走近罗伊，他声称自己是来保护妻子的。警察劝他离开。在伊恩·马尔格鲁（Ian Mulgrew）所著的关于辛迪·梅克皮斯的书中，辛迪告诉帕特·麦克布莱德警员，有一天晚上她醒来听到窗户有敲击声。惊恐万分的她拉开窗帘，发现罗伊正站在那里，手里拿着一把刀和一支步枪。他告诉辛迪安心睡觉，因为他在守护她的住所。第二天，罗伊向辛迪讲述了当晚的事情，并解释了他的理论：可能有人来自黑手党，想要对她不利。
He told Cindy that the phone calls, the stalker activity and the slashed pillow were reminiscent of scenes from the crime film The Godfather. Roy thought that Cindy may have upset the family of one of her patients and that they were terrorizing her as a way of exacting revenge. He warned Cindy not to use the downstairs laundry room as someone could easily slip in there and slit her throat, remarking that she wouldn't be found for days. Roy asked Cindy to move back in with him and was angered when she refused. In late December, Roy went with Cindy to her parents' place on Vancouver Island for the holidays. The pair exchanged gifts like old times, although it was obvious that their relationship was strained. On January 15 the following year, Officer Pat McBride was visiting Cindy when she received a phone call. McBride listened in. There was no voice on the other line, however, a woman's voice over a PA system was audible in the background.
他告诉辛迪，这些电话、跟踪活动和被划破的枕头让人想起犯罪电影《教父》中的场景。罗伊认为辛迪可能惹恼了她某位病人的家属，而他们正在用这种方式恐吓她以进行报复。他警告辛迪不要使用楼下的洗衣房，因为有人可以轻易溜进去割断她的喉咙，并指出她可能好几天都不会被发现。罗伊要求辛迪搬回和他一起住，遭到拒绝后勃然大怒。12 月下旬，罗伊和辛迪一起去温哥华岛的父母家过节。两人像从前一样互赠礼物，尽管很明显他们的关系已经很紧张。第二年 1 月 15 日，帕特·麦克布莱德警员正在拜访辛迪时，她接到了一个电话。麦克布莱德在一旁聆听。听筒那头没有人说话，然而背景音里能听到公共广播系统里一个女人的声音。
It sounded like the call was coming from an airport. A wiretap had been placed on Cindy's phone, though the caller didn't stay on the line long enough for a full trace. But a partial trace placed the call as coming from the Richmond area, the location of Vancouver Airport. On the night of January 27, Cindy was feeling particularly anxious. Her friend Agnes Woodcock told Cindy that she would stay the night so she had someone else in the house with her. Cindy gratefully accepted the offer. While she waited for Agnes to arrive, Cindy decided to move some old boxes into the garage. As she went to turn on the garage light, she realised that wasn't working.
听起来这通电话像是从机场打来的。辛迪的电话上被安装了窃听器，不过来电者在电话线上停留的时间不够长，无法进行完整的追踪。但部分追踪显示，这通电话来自里士满地区，即温哥华机场所在地。1 月 27 日晚，辛迪感到格外焦虑。她的朋友阿格尼丝·伍德科克告诉辛迪，她会留下来过夜，这样家里就还有另一个人陪着她。辛迪感激地接受了这个提议。在等待阿格尼丝到达的同时，辛迪决定把一些旧箱子搬到车库去。当她去开车库灯时，她发现灯不亮了。
Suddenly, someone grabbed Cindy by her right arm and told her to keep quiet. Cindy felt a pimp-rick on her right shoulder and although she tried to fight off her assailant, soon became drowsy. The man held a knife and threatened to cut her face if she cried out. She felt something tight being wrapped around her neck and tried to get a glimpse of her attacker as she struggled to breathe. He was wearing tight gloves and running shoes, but in the darkness, all his features were hidden. The man went to leave and as he closed the garage door said to Cindy, it will take a long time to die. Agnes arrived at 9.30pm and heard a moaning sound coming from the basement stairwell.
突然，有人抓住了辛迪的右臂，并告诉她保持安静。辛迪感到右肩被针扎了一下，尽管她试图挣脱袭击者，但很快就昏昏欲睡起来。那名男子拿着一把刀，威胁说如果她大叫就会割破她的脸。她感觉到有什么紧绷的东西缠绕在她的脖子上，在呼吸困难的同时，她试图瞥一眼袭击者。他戴着紧身的防护手套，穿着跑鞋，但在黑暗中，他的所有特征都被隐藏了。这名男子准备离开，在关上车库门时对辛迪说：“死需要很长时间。”阿格尼丝于晚上 9 点 30 分到达，听到地下室楼梯间传来呻吟声。
She found Cindy with the black stocking wrapped tightly around her neck and numerous cuts on her body. Cindy was taken to Vancouver General Hospital where she was treated for 14 cuts to her back, shoulders and legs. The emergency doctor thought they had been caused by a razor or scalpel given the neatness of the incisions. She also had a strangulation mark around her neck caused by the stocking, bruises to her face and what appeared to be a puncture mark from a needle on her right arm. Cindy was hazy about the events. She did her best to recount what happened to her to the doctor and to Detective David Boyer Smith who was assigned to the investigation. Roy Makepeace was considered the prime suspect in Cindy's attack. He gave an alibi for the night explaining that he had worked late until about 9 before getting some dinner at a restaurant a few kilometres from Cindy's house. He then said he got home after 10 remembering that the late news had already started on television.
她发现辛迪的脖子上紧紧缠着一条黑色长筒袜，身上有多处割伤。辛迪被送到温哥华总医院，在那里接受了背部、肩膀和腿部共 14 处伤口的治疗。急诊医生认为，鉴于切口非常整齐，这些伤口可能是由剃须刀或手术刀造成的。她的脖子上也有一道由长筒袜勒出的勒痕，面部有瘀伤，右手臂上似乎有一个针孔。对于发生的事件，辛迪记忆有些模糊。她尽最大努力向医生以及被指派负责此案调查的侦探大卫·博耶·史密斯（David Boyer Smith）复述了她遭遇的事情。罗伊·梅特皮斯被认为是袭击辛迪的主要嫌疑人。他为当晚提供了一个不在场证明，解释说他工作到很晚，大约 9 点才在离辛迪家几公里远的一家餐厅吃晚饭。然后他说他在 10 点多回到家，记起电视上的深夜新闻已经开始了。
Roy agreed to take a polygraph test to confirm his alibi but it never went ahead. Medications that Roy took for a heart problem could result in false positives and the stress of the test could trigger his condition. Roy Makepeace was free to leave. Following the assault Cindy moved into a bungalow-style house closer to her workplace. Friends thought Cindy would be safer in an apartment building with secure access but Cindy turned down the idea. She wanted a garden to tend to and space for her dog Heidi to run around. Cindy refused to divulge much information about the attack to family and friends not wanting to burden them with her troubles. An intensely private person, Cindy felt the attack was hers to deal with on her own.
罗伊同意接受测谎仪测试以证实他的不在场证明，但测试最终没有进行。罗伊因心脏问题所服用的药物可能会导致假阳性结果，而且测试带来的压力可能会引发他的病情。罗伊·梅特皮斯得以离开。袭击发生后，辛迪搬进了一栋离她工作地点更近的平房式住宅。朋友们认为辛迪住在有安全门禁的公寓楼里会更安全，但辛迪拒绝了这个想法。她想要一个可以照料的花园，以及供她的狗海蒂四处奔跑的空间。辛迪拒绝向家人和朋友透露太多关于袭击的细节，不想用自己的烦恼连累他们。作为一个极其注重隐私的人，辛迪觉得这次袭击是她自己的事，必须独自处理。
However, as a last resort Cindy began seeing GP Dr Alan Connolly to discuss her problems. She declined seeing a psychiatrist because she didn't want the stigma attached to seeking professional help. Cindy confided to Connolly that she thought she would never feel safe walking down the street again. Soon Dr Connolly began seeing Cindy in her home and stopped charging for visits. He became more of a friend than a doctor even though he continued prescribing her medications for anxiety and to help her sleep. Not long after the move Cindy started receiving letters at work. Addressed to her the words and letters were cut from magazines and to newspapers. The threatening messages inside such as soon Cindy and your dead cunt terrified her and she promptly tore up the letters and threw them away.
然而，作为最后的手段，辛迪开始去看全科医生艾伦·康利（Dr Alan Connolly）博士以讨论她的问题。她拒绝看精神病学家，因为她不想承受寻求专业帮助所带来的污名。辛迪向康利吐露，她觉得自己再也不敢走在街上了。不久，康利博士开始去辛迪家中为她看病，并且不再收取看诊费。他与其说是一个医生，不如说更像是一个朋友，尽管他继续为她开具抗焦虑和帮助睡眠的药物。搬家后不久，辛迪开始在单位收到信件。信封是写给她的，上面的字和信件内容都是从杂志和报纸上剪下来的。里面的威胁信息，例如“辛迪快了，你这个死婊子”，让她感到极度恐惧，她随即把信撕碎并扔掉了。
On other occasions she threw the unopened letters straight into the bin. On October 15 1983 Cindy heard Heidi barking outside. When she went to investigate she found a dead cat in her yard with a note nearby that read, your next. No prints were found on the paper. One month later Cindy hired private investigator Ozzie Caban at the suggestion of Officer Pat McBride. The physical attack on Cindy had been marked inactive due to a lack of leads. Cindy felt that the Vancouver police department wasn't interested in catching her assailant. She hoped Ozzie would get her the answers she needed.
有时她会把未拆开的信直接扔进垃圾桶。1983 年 10 月 15 日，辛迪听到海蒂在外面狂吠。当她去查看时，发现院子里有一只死猫，附近有一张纸条，上面写着：“下一个就是你。”纸上没有找到指纹。一个月后，在帕特·麦克布莱德警员的建议下，辛迪雇用了私家侦探奥齐·卡班（Ozzie Caban）。由于缺乏线索，针对辛迪的身体袭击案已被标记为不活跃状态。辛迪觉得温哥华警察局对抓住她的袭击者不感兴趣。她希望奥齐能为她找到她需要的答案。
Ozzie gave Cindy a two way radio with a panic button that she could use in case of emergency. Given that Cindy's phone lines had been cut at her new house as well. The hang up calls also continued now occurring at Cindy's workplace Blenheim House. Cindy's co-workers were becoming concerned as the brightened bubbly Cindy now seemed frightened and withdrawn. One day Cindy awoke to find that her new garden she had put so many hours into had been trampled. Flowers and plants were dug up and strewn around. It was reminiscent of a time Roy Matepeace had lost his temper and gone on a similar rampage when they were living together. Cindy's co-workers discussed the attacks when she wasn't in earshot.
奥齐给了辛迪一个带紧急按钮的双向对讲机，以防发生紧急情况。鉴于辛迪在新家的电话线也被切断了。挂断电话的情况也仍在继续，现在甚至出现在辛迪的工作单位布伦海姆之家。辛迪的同事们开始感到担忧，因为原本开朗活泼的辛迪现在看起来既害怕又孤僻。一天，辛迪醒来发现她花了那么多心血打理的新花园被人踩踏了。花草被挖出来，到处乱扔。这让人想起罗伊·梅特皮斯在他们同居时发脾气并进行类似大肆破坏的情形。辛迪的同事们在她听不见的地方讨论了这些袭击事件。
They recalled when she had come to work in 1981 with a foot and leg injury. She told them that she had injured herself playing racquetball but later confided to speech pathologist Sue Fisk that Roy had pushed her down the stairs. Sue also recalled at Christmas that year that Cindy had come to work with a black eye. She walked into Cindy's office later that day to find Roy Matepeace embracing Cindy saying, I'm sorry I did that to you. Roy's temper intensified. Cindy confided to another employee that she required reconstructive breast surgery following one particularly violent assault. Her colleagues were relieved in 1982 when Cindy, with another black eye, told them that she and Roy were separating.
他们回忆起她在 1981 年上班时脚和腿受过伤。她告诉他们自己是打壁球时受伤的，但后来向言语治疗师苏·菲斯克（Sue Fisk）吐露，是罗伊把她推下楼梯的。苏还回忆起那年的圣诞节，辛迪带着黑眼圈来上班。那天晚些时候，她走进辛迪的办公室，发现罗伊·梅特皮斯正拥抱着辛迪，说：“对不起，我那样对你。”罗伊的脾气愈演愈烈。辛迪向另一名员工吐露，在经历了一次特别暴力的袭击后，她需要进行乳房重建手术。1982 年，当辛迪带着另一个黑眼圈告诉同事她和罗伊分居时，同事们都松了一口气。
However, Cindy was adamant that Roy was not responsible for the spate of attacks. They still went to dinner and dated regularly. Cindy even broke off her relationship with Pat McBride telling him that things were moving too quickly for her. On January 30, just before 6pm, Ozzie Caban was informed by his security company that an odd rustling sound was coming from the two-way radio owned by Cindy. He made his way to Cindy's house and knocked on the locked door. When Cindy failed to answer, Ozzie peered through the front window. Scanning the interior, he could make out Cindy lying on her back on the floor of the hallway. Her long blonde hair was covering her face.
然而，辛迪坚称罗伊不应对这一连串的袭击负责。他们仍然一起吃晚餐并经常约会。辛迪甚至中断了与帕特·麦克布莱德的关系，告诉他事情对她来说进展太快了。1月30日傍晚6点前不久，奥齐·卡班接到他的保安公司通知，称辛迪名下的双向对讲机里传出奇怪的沙沙声。他赶到辛迪家，敲了敲反锁的门。见辛迪没有应答，奥齐透过前窗往里看。环顾室内，他隐约看到辛迪仰面躺在走廊的地板上。她长长的金发遮住了脸。
After returning to his car to alert the police, Ozzie kicked the front door down and yelled, Come out you son of a bitch, I'll kill you. He rushed to Cindy. She was unconscious, cold and clammy with a visible bump to her head. Her left arm was outstretched and a note was stuck to her left hand, secured in place by a peering knife that pierced her skin and went into the floor below. The note, made of letters cut from newspapers and magazines, read, Now you must die. Paramedics arrived and a hospital attendant noticed something hidden in between the skin folds of Cindy's neck.
回到车里报警后，奥齐一脚踢开前门，大喊道：“给老子滚出来，我要宰了你。”他冲向辛迪。她已经失去知觉，身体冰凉湿冷，头部有明显的肿块。她的左臂伸展着，左手上贴着一张纸条，纸条被一把刺入皮肤并扎进下方地板的小刀固定在原位。这张纸条是用从报纸和杂志上剪下的字母拼成的，上面写着：“现在你必须死。”急救人员赶到了，一名医院护理人员注意到辛迪颈部的皮肤褶皱之间藏着什么东西。
Tired so tightly it was initially obscured from view, was a black nylon stocking. Scans revealed Cindy had not sustained any brain damage from being strangled and she was released from hospital the next day. She told the police that she had returned home from work approximately an hour before the attack. She was unlocking her back door to let Heidi inside when she saw a man coming through the side gate of her house. Cindy thought it was a neighbor and called out to him, but the man remained silent and walked briskly up the stairs to her. Cindy began to panic and was frozen in fear. The man struck her over the head with something. She couldn't recall the events that followed other than waking up on the kitchen floor with the impression that there were two men with her. After they left, Cindy remembered crawling to the hallway to retrieve the two-way radio and trying to contact Ozzy.
由于系得太紧，它最初被遮挡住了，那是一条黑色的尼龙长筒袜。扫描结果显示，辛迪并没有因被勒而遭受任何脑损伤，她于第二天出院。她告诉警方，她在袭击发生前大约一个小时从单位回家。她正在开后门让海蒂进来时，看到一个男子从她家的侧门走进来。辛迪以为是邻居，便喊了他一声，但该男子一言不发，快步顺着楼梯朝她走来。辛迪开始感到恐慌，吓得僵在原地。男子用某种东西击中了她的头部。除了醒来时发现自己躺在厨房地板上有两个人在她身边的印象外，她记不清随后的事情了。他们离开后，辛迪记得自己爬向走廊去拿双向对讲机并试图联系奥齐。
Cindy described her main attacker to Ozzy. He had a brown mustache, blue eyes and was wearing a blue nylon jacket. She confided to Ozzy that she hadn't given the police his description as he had threatened to kill her sisters if she told them anything. Despite Ozzy's encouragement, she refused to disclose any information about the attack to authorities other than the basic details. On February 14, Roy Makepeace was questioned about the incident. Detective David Boyer-Smith believed him to be responsible for the attack. In a six-hour interrogation, he continued to barrage Roy in an attempt to get him to crack. He warned Roy that he would be charged with two acts of attempted murder over the two physical assaults. After refusing to give in, Detective Boyer-Smith told Roy that Cindy had given him up, finally telling police that she believed he was the perpetrator behind the attacks on her.
辛迪向奥齐描述了她的主要袭击者特征。他留着棕色小胡子，蓝色眼睛，穿着一件蓝色尼龙夹克。她向奥齐吐露，她没有把这个体貌特征告诉警方，因为对方威胁说如果她透露任何信息就会杀了她的妹妹们。尽管奥齐百般鼓励，她除了基本细节外，还是拒绝向当局透露任何关于袭击的信息。2 月 14 日，罗伊·梅特皮斯就这起事件接受了讯问。侦探大卫·博耶·史密斯认为他对这次袭击负有责任。在长达六小时的审讯中，他不断向罗伊施压，试图让他崩溃。他警告罗伊，他将因两次身体袭击而被控两项谋杀未遂罪。在罗伊拒绝屈服后，大卫·博耶·史密斯侦探告诉罗伊，辛迪已经把他供出来了，最终告诉警方她相信他就是袭击她的幕后黑手。
She had told detectives that he was a violent man and she was terrified of him. Roy steadfastly denied any involvement, however, admitted to slapping Cindy on two occasions when they were living together. He denied ever punching Cindy, giving her black eyes or any of the other incidences of assault she claimed. Roy maintained his theory that the mafia were involved in the attacks and explained this to the dubious detectives. With no evidence to charge him, Roy was allowed to leave the station. Cindy recuperated from her ordeal and took a brief holiday to her parents' bungalow on Vancouver Island. The respite did her good and Cindy returned to work happy and upbeat. Following the previous attack four months prior, Cindy and Ozzy had devised a safety plan.
她告诉侦探，他是一个暴力的人，她非常怕他。罗伊坚决否认自己有任何涉案行为，但承认在他们同居期间曾扇过辛迪两巴掌。他否认自己曾殴打过辛迪、打出过黑眼圈，或者实施过她所声称的其他任何袭击事件。罗伊坚持他关于黑手党卷入袭击的理论，并向将信将疑的侦探们解释了这一点。由于没有证据起诉他，罗伊获准离开警察局。辛迪从这场磨难中恢复过来，并在温哥华岛父母的平房里度过了一个短暂的假期。这次休假对她大有益处，辛迪高高兴兴、精神饱满地回到了工作岗位。继四个月前的上一次袭击之后，辛迪和奥齐制定了一项安全计划。
She would call his firm when she was leaving her house and also when she returned so that Ozzy knew she was unharmed. On July 23 at 8.16pm, Cindy phoned Ozzy Caban's security company to let them know she was taking Heidi for a quick walk in a nearby park and would return in an hour. It was a warm night and Cindy watched the tennis players at the nearby community centre. As she walked along, a green van pulled up alongside her. Its driver was a man with long dark hair, a bushy beard and wearing square horn-rimmed glasses. He spoke to her through the open passenger window while leaning across a blonde-haired female in the passenger seat. He asked, Excuse me ma'am, do you know where Churchill Street is? Cindy started to give directions.
她会在离开家以及回到家时分别给他的公司打电话，以便奥齐知道她安然无恙。7 月 23 日晚上 8 点 16 分，辛迪致电奥齐·卡班的保安公司，让他们知道她要带海蒂去附近的公园散一会儿步，一个小时后就会回来。这是一个温暖的夜晚，辛迪看着附近社区中心的网球运动员打球。当她往前走时，一辆绿色的货车在她身旁停了下来。开车的是一个留着长黑发、浓密胡须、戴着方形框镜的男子。他探身越过副驾驶座上一名金发女子，通过开着的副驾驶车窗对她说话。他问：“请问女士，你知道丘吉尔街在哪里吗？”辛迪开始为他指路。
Approximately three hours later, Regan Trethway heard a strange noise. He looked out the front window of his house and saw a blonde woman trying to open his front door. It was Cindy made peace. She mouthed some words to him and was about to lose consciousness. As she pointed to her throat, Regan could make out a black stocking tied tightly around her neck. He cut the ligature with difficulty as it was so tight he couldn't get his fingers under it. Treating doctors at the University of BC Hospital Emergency Department did not know what to make of the attack. Cindy had puffy red eyes from being strangled, a bloody left nostril and a sore right ankle. Ozzie Caban had met Cindy at Regan Trethway's before she was transported by ambulance.
大约三个小时后，雷根·特雷思韦（Regan Trethway）听到了一种奇怪的声音。他望向自己家的前窗，看到一个金发女子正试图打开他的前门。那是辛迪·梅克皮斯。她对他说着无声的话，眼看就要失去知觉。当她指着自己的喉咙时，雷根辨认出一条黑色长筒袜紧紧缠绕在她的脖子上。他费力地割断了勒带，因为它勒得太紧，他的手指根本塞不进去。不列颠哥伦比亚大学医院急诊科的主治医生们不知道该如何应对这起袭击。辛迪因为被勒而充血红肿，左鼻孔流血，右脚踝疼痛。奥齐·卡班在辛迪被救护车运走之前，在雷根·特雷思韦家见到了她。
He informed the doctors of two fresh needle puncture marks he had seen on Cindy's inner elbow. Toxicology tests were run which showed the presence of benzodiazepines in Cindy's bloodstream, but did not give a result as to the concentration of drugs in her system. When they undressed her, nursing staff found twigs and leaves in her underwear. Cindy's recollection of events was hazy. She didn't remember anything after giving the man in the van directions. The next thing she recalled was speaking to a doctor in the hospital. A search of Dunbar Park where Cindy was abducted located one of her shoes, the canister of dog repellent she carried for protection with a drag mark in the dirt about 10 meters from the sidewalk where the van pulled up.
他向医生通报了他在辛迪内肘处看到的两个新鲜针孔。医院进行了毒理学测试，结果显示辛迪的血液中存在苯二氮䓬类药物，但未测出其体内的药物浓度。当护理人员脱掉她的衣服时，在她的内衣里发现了树枝和树叶。辛迪对事件的记忆有些模糊。在给面包车里的男人指路后，她什么也不记得了。她记忆中的下一件事就是在医院里和医生说话。对辛迪被绑架的邓巴公园（Dunbar Park）的搜查找到了她的一只鞋、她随身携带用于防身的小罐狗驱虫剂，在离面包车停下的马路边约 10 米处的泥土里还有一道拖曳痕迹。
Later that evening in the emergency department, clerk Lisa Latimore received a call. The call was received directly at the emergency desk by passing the hospital switchboard system. A man on the line asked, do you have hospital security? When Lisa asked him to clarify what he meant, the man replied, do you have security guards? He also asked what time the emergency department closed. The perplexed clerk advised the man that it didn't close. He went on to ask how many floors the hospital had. Not wanting to divulge any further information, Lisa told the man she would transfer him to her supervisor.
那天晚上晚些时候在急诊室，文员丽莎·拉蒂莫尔（Lisa Latimore）接到了一个电话。这通电话是直接打到急诊前台的，绕过了医院的总机系统。线上的一个男人问：“你们有医院保安吗？”当丽莎请他澄清他的意思时，该男子回答说：“你们有保安吗？”他还问急诊室几点关门。这位困惑的文员告诉该男子急诊室是24小时不关门的。接着他又问医院有多少层。丽莎不想透露更多信息，便告诉该男子她会把他转接给主管。
The man abruptly hung up. Lisa reported the unusual call to Detective David Boyer Smith who was at the hospital interviewing Cindy Makepeace. She told him that the caller had a strange accent, possibly of South African or New Zealand extraction. In an attempt to remember details of the past attacks, Cindy agreed to undergo sessions of hypnosis. In the book about Cindy Makepeace by Neil Hall, the sessions were successful. Cindy was able to recall from the latest attack the model of the van that it had chrome mirrors, a rubber pad on the bumper and a smoky coloured air vent on top. She recalled being dragged into the van which had carpeting in the back and several people inside.
该男子挂断了电话。丽莎将这通不同寻常的电话报告给了正在医院采访辛迪·梅克皮斯的侦探大卫·博耶·史密斯。她告诉他，来电者有一种奇怪的口音，可能是南非或新西兰口音。为了尝试回忆过去袭击的细节，辛迪同意接受催眠治疗。在尼尔·霍尔（Neil Hall）所著的关于辛迪·梅克皮斯的书中，这些治疗很成功。辛迪能够从最近的一次袭击中回忆起那辆面包车的型号：它有镀铬后视镜、保险杠上有橡胶垫，顶部有一个烟灰色的通风口。她回忆起自己被拖进了一辆面包车，车后面铺着地毯，里面有几个人。
One had a mask and a wig on. She felt a sharp prick on her arm and a voice surrounding her. One of the voices uttered the word hombergosh. Cindy explained that this was a South African Zulu word that translated to be warned, do as I say. Roy Makepeace was South African and spoke with a strong accent. At the third hypnosis session held on October 2, Cindy made a startling revelation. She recalled a trip that she and Roy had taken on board the peacemaker just over three years earlier in July 1981. They had sailed to an isolated area of the Gulf Islands, approximately 75 kilometres from Vancouver.
其中一个人戴着面具和假发。她感到手臂上被刺了一下，周围响起了说话声。其中一个声音吐出了“hombergosh”这个词。辛迪解释说，这是一个南非祖鲁语单词，翻译过来就是“当心，照我说的做”。罗伊·梅特皮斯是南非人，说话带有浓重的口音。在 10 月 2 日举行的第三次催眠治疗中，辛迪有了一个惊人的发现。她回想起三年多前的 1981 年 7 月，她和罗伊乘坐“和平缔造者”号进行的一次旅行。他们航行到了海湾群岛（Gulf Islands）的一个偏远地区，距离温哥华大约 75 公里。
As they tied up to the wharf, Cindy decided to stay below and take a nap while Roy went to look at some property on the island. Becoming visibly distressed during the hypnosis session, Cindy recounted how she heard some shouting. After putting on her jeans and shoes, she went above deck and shouted back. No one responded. She investigated the noise, happening upon a log cabin further inland at the top of a hill. She approached the front porch. Firewood was stacked neatly to one side. Cindy knocked on the door, but there was no answer. She cautiously opened the door to see Roy Makepeace standing there.
当他们把船系在码头上时，辛迪决定留在船舱下面打个盹，而罗伊则去岛上看一些房产。在催眠治疗中表现出明显的痛苦，辛迪讲述了她听到一些喊叫声的过程。穿上牛仔裤和鞋子后，她走到甲板上并大声喊回去。没有人回应。她去查明噪音的来源，偶然发现了一个位于内陆小山顶上的木屋。她走近前廊。一侧整齐地堆放着木柴。辛迪敲了敲门，但无人应答。她小心翼翼地推开门，看到罗伊·梅特皮斯正站在那里。
He was very angry. On the floor were the bodies of two people, a man in his 30s and a woman in her 20s. Roy was holding a knife. It was covered in blood. Running from the cabin, Cindy screamed out to Roy that he was a murderer and vomited. Roy caught up to Cindy, slapped her on the face and shook her. The next thing she remembered was sitting on a bed while Roy hacked the bodies into pieces with an axe to dispose of in the ocean. From the book by Neil Hall, Cindy told the hypnotherapist, I don't know how I got there. I'm just sitting on the bed. I'm numb as if in a shell.
他非常生气。地板上躺着两具尸体，一个 30 多岁的男人和一个 20 多岁的女人。罗伊手里拿着一把刀。刀上沾满了血。辛迪从木屋里跑出来，尖叫着对罗伊说他是个杀人犯，并吐了。罗伊追上辛迪，扇了她耳光并摇晃她。她记忆中的下一件事就是坐在床边，看着罗伊用斧头将尸体剁成碎块以便扔进大海。根据尼尔·霍尔的书，辛迪对催眠治疗师说：“我不知道我是怎么到那里的。我只是坐在床上。我麻木得就像在一个空壳里。”
But part of me is screaming inside. Detectives attempted to pinpoint the cabin that Cindy had described in her hypnotherapy sessions. It was a difficult task given that Cindy was asleep when they docked and didn't know where the cabin was located in the vast expanse of the Gulf Islands. Although she could recall the interior with clarity, a rough wooden floor, great blanket, a wooden cupboard stacked with books, an old table that had writing paper on it, a wood stove and maps on the wall. The exterior offered no distinguishing features. The Royal Canadian Mounted Police searched the area described by Cindy for a full day but could not locate the cabin. Employing another tactic, Cindy agreed to call her husband using a phone that was tapped by police.
“但我的内心有一部分在尖叫。”侦探们试图精确确定辛迪在催眠治疗中描述的小屋。这是一项艰巨的任务，因为辛迪靠岸时正在睡觉，并且不知道在广袤的海湾群岛中那间小屋的具体位置。尽管她能清晰地回忆起内部陈设：粗糙的木地板、灰色的毯子、堆满书的木橱柜、一张放着信纸的旧桌子、一个燃木炉以及墙上的地图。但外观没有任何明显的特征。加拿大皇家骑警在辛迪描述的地区搜查了一整天，但没有找到那间小屋。采取了另一种策略后，辛迪同意使用被警方窃听的电话给她的丈夫打电话。
On July 2, 1985, Roy made Peace's telephone ring. He was surprised to hear Cindy on the other line. They had not spoken since he found out she thought him responsible for the attacks. She began the conversation. With the help of hypnosis, I've been able to remember a lot of why things are happening and what happened four years ago. I wanted to talk to you before letting the police know that I now remember everything. Roy listened as Cindy recounted the bodies in the log cabin. He sounded shocked and angry when she told him she believed he was responsible for the attacks on her and denied any wrongdoing,
1985 年 7 月 2 日，罗伊·梅特皮斯的电话响了。听到听筒那头是辛迪，他感到很惊讶。自从他发现她认为他是袭击事件的幕后黑手以来，他们就再也没有说过话。她开始了对话。在催眠的帮助下，我能够回想起很多事情发生的原因以及四年前发生的事。在让警方知道我现在想通了一切之前，我想和你谈谈。罗伊听着辛迪叙述木屋里的尸体。当辛迪告诉他，她相信他对针对她的袭击事件负有责任时，他听起来既震惊又愤怒，并否认了任何不当行为，
telling Cindy he had nothing to do with it. As she terminated the call, Cindy said, We both know that you have been doing it. I'm not going to listen to that garbage anymore. Immediately following the call, Cindy and Roy Makepeace were placed on round the clock surveillance. This was ceased five days later due to the expense and resources required. During this time, Roy made no attempt to contact or harm Cindy. Six months later, on December 11, Cindy left work on her lunch break and didn't return. That night, Desiree El-Zesa was cycling near the University of British Columbia.
告诉辛迪他对此一无所知。就在她挂断电话时，辛迪说：“我们都知道你一直在这么做。我再也不会听这些鬼话了。”通话结束后不久，辛迪和罗伊·梅克皮斯（Roy Makepeace）受到了全天候监控。由于所需的费用和资源，这项监控在五天后停止。在此期间，罗伊没有试图联系或伤害辛迪。六个月后的12月11日，辛迪在午休时离开工作岗位，没有返回。那天晚上，黛西雷·埃尔-泽萨（Desiree El-Zesa）正在不列颠哥伦比亚大学附近骑自行车。
It was freezing cold as she rode along West 16th Avenue. The December sun had well and truly set by 6.20 as Desiree came to the intersection of Blanca Street. She stopped when something caught her eye. A blonde woman staggered before falling into a ditch across the street. Racing over to her, Desiree noticed the woman had a black stocking wrapped tightly around her neck. She managed to tear the stocking off with her bare hands and called an ambulance. When paramedics arrived, they found Cindy Makepeace standing in the ditch dazed with icy cold water up to her thighs. She was wearing regular clothes with the addition of a black rubber industrial glove on her right hand.
当她沿着西第16大道骑行时，天气冷得结冰。当黛西雷来到布兰卡街（Blanca Street）交叉口时，12月的太阳早已完全落山。当有什么东西吸引了她的目光时，她停了下来。一个金发女郎摇摇晃晃地走着，然后倒在了街对面的沟里。黛西雷跑过去，发现这个女人的脖子上紧紧缠着一只黑色长筒袜。她设法用双手扯下长筒袜并叫了救护车。当护理人员到达时，他们发现辛迪·梅克皮斯正茫然地站在沟里，冰冷的水没到了大腿。她穿着便服，右手戴着一只黑色橡胶工业手套。
One of her feet was bare, the other had on a man's work boot. Concerned about hypothermia, a paramedic coaxed Cindy out of the water and worked on warming her as he took her to the University of BC Hospital. Cindy had scratches on her upper chest, arms, legs and back that looked like they were caused from fingernails or tree branches. She had a dark bruise to her forehead. There was a fresh puncture wound to Cindy's right elbow, indicating that she had been drugged. Blood testing showed the presence of benzodiazepines in her bloodstream. However, Cindy also told the treating doctor she had taken 6 milligrams of the drug Adavan for anxiety earlier in the day. As with previous attacks, Cindy couldn't remember what had happened to her, only events before and after.
她一只脚赤脚，另一只脚穿着男式工作靴。出于对低体温症的担心，一名护理人员劝辛迪走出水面，并在将她送往不列颠哥伦比亚大学医院的途中为她保暖。辛迪的上胸部、手臂、腿和背部有抓痕，看起来像是指甲或树枝造成的。她的前额有一处深色瘀伤。辛迪的右肘有一个新鲜的针刺伤口，表明她被下药了。血液检测显示她的血液中含有苯二氮卓类药物。然而，辛迪也告诉主治医生，她当天早些时候为了焦虑服用了6毫克的阿蒂万（Adavan）。与之前的袭击一样，辛迪记不清自己身上发生了什么，只记得事发前后的事情。
She recalled leaving Blenheim House for lunch and driving to the chemist to pick up her prescription for Adavan. The next thing she recalled was going to the hospital in the ambulance, although she had a vague memory of having her hands tied behind her in an unfamiliar room. Cindy poured her feelings out in her personal diary. She wrote, I don't know why it bothers me so much that I can still only remember bits and pieces of what happened the last time I was attacked. I don't know which is worse, remembering or not being able to remember. I think it would be better if I had total amnesia about it, although it feels so helpless to know things were done to you and you don't know what they were. The police reaction was so confusing. If nothing else, I learned not to talk to anyone about it. Cindy returned to work shortly after the attack, but the experience had a profound effect on her.
她回忆起离开布伦海姆大楼（Blenheim House）吃午饭，开车去药房取阿蒂万的处方药。她接下来回忆的事就是坐救护车去医院，尽管她依稀记得在某个陌生房间里双手被反绑在身后。辛迪在个人日记中倾诉了自己的感受。她写道：“我不知道为什么我还是只能记起上次被袭击时发生的事情的零星片段，这让我如此烦恼。我不知道是记得还是记不清哪个更糟糕。我想如果我对这件事完全失忆会更好，尽管明知道事情发生在你身上却不知道是什么感觉是如此无助。警察的反应太令人困惑了。不管怎样，我学会了不要跟任何人谈论这件事。”袭击发生后不久，辛迪重返工作岗位，但这段经历对她产生了深远的影响。
She became further withdrawn, and it was obvious to her co-workers that she was no longer coping with the demands of her work. She looked exhausted. The dark circles around her eyes accentuated by her pale skin. Cindy felt she had no choice but to move house again. She relocated from Vancouver to the city of Richmond, 15 kilometres south. Things settled down, and Cindy enjoyed the garden at her new rental house, a modest brown and white timber multi-leveled home. Cindy's close friends, Tom and Agnes Woodcock, came over on the night of April 12, 1986, four months after the attack in the park. They played cards and decided to stay the night, retiring to bed at 11 o'clock. At 2am, Tom heard a loud thump coming from downstairs. He was putting on his pants when Cindy knocked on his door. She had heard the same noise and asked Tom if he would go with her to investigate.
她变得更加孤僻，同事们明显看出她已经无法应对工作上的要求。她看起来筋疲力尽。苍白的皮肤衬托出她眼下的黑眼圈。辛迪觉得自己别无选择，只能再次搬家。她从温哥华搬到了南面15公里外的列治文市。情况安定下来后，辛迪很喜欢她新租的房子的花园，这是一栋朴素的棕白相间多层木结构住宅。1986年4月12日晚上，即公园袭击事件发生四个月后，辛迪的挚友汤姆和艾格尼丝·伍德科克（Tom and Agnes Woodcock）来到了她家。他们玩了牌，决定留宿，并在11点就寝。凌晨2点，汤姆听到楼下传来一声巨响。他正穿着裤子时，辛迪敲了他的房门。她听到了同样的噪音，并问汤姆是否愿意和她一起去查看。
They made their way down the hallway together. As Tom passed the window of the living room, he could see flames coming from the basement below them. He shouted to his wife Agnes to phone for the fire brigade. Agnes soon returned, telling Tom that the phone line was dead. In response, Tom raced outside to flag down anyone who might be able to help. He saw a man in his 30s standing near Cindy's house and called to him, asking the man to phone for assistance. The man didn't reply, instead running down a side street and disappearing into the night. The fire was quickly brought under control and extinguished by the Richmond Fire Department at 2.52am.
他们一起顺着走廊走去。当汤姆经过客厅窗户时，他可以看到他们下方的地下室冒出火焰。他大声喊妻子艾格尼丝报警。艾格尼丝很快回来了，告诉汤姆电话线断了。作为回应，汤姆冲到外面去拦下任何可能提供帮助的人。他看到一个30多岁的男人站在辛迪家附近，便向他大喊，请这个人打电话求助。这个男人没有回答，而是跑进一条小巷，消失在夜色中。大火很快被列治文消防局控制并于凌晨2点52分扑灭。
Damage was confined to the basement area and Cindy, her guests and her dog were unharmed. An investigation by authorities and a specialist fire investigator could not find any evidence to suggest who might be responsible for the blaze. Cindy thought Roy Makepeace was to blame. The fire was a massive setback to Cindy. She became increasingly despondent in the weeks that followed. The major depression that arose from Cindy, realizing that the attacks had followed her to her new place, resulted in a stay at St. Paul's Psychiatric Unit. Gradually, Cindy's mental health improved and on discharge from the hospital, she finalized her relationship with Roy Makepeace, officially divorcing in June 1986. To mark the end of the marriage, Cindy changed her surname from Makepeace to James. Rather than returning to her maiden name of Hack, Cindy liked the short, easy to remember surname of James and the new beginning at Signified.
损毁仅限于地下室区域，辛迪、她的客人和她的狗都没有受伤。当局和专业火灾调查员的调查未能找到任何证据来指明谁可能是这场火灾的负责人。辛迪认为罗伊·梅克皮斯难辞其咎。这场火灾对辛迪是一个沉重的打击。在随后的几周里，她变得越来越沮丧。辛迪意识到袭击一直追到她的新住所，由此产生的大(严重)抑郁症导致她在圣保罗精神病房住院。渐渐地，辛迪的心理健康有所改善，出院后，她终结了与罗伊·梅克皮斯的关系，于1986年6月正式离婚。为了标志这段婚姻的结束，辛迪将姓氏从梅克皮斯改为了詹姆斯（James）。辛迪没有恢复娘家姓哈克（Hack），而是喜欢简短、易记的姓氏詹姆斯以及在Signified的新开始。
In mid-1986, Cindy went to Germany to visit and stay with her brother Roger who worked there. On return, Cindy, who had taken six months of sick leave, felt well enough to go back to work. She was immediately asked to resign. It had been decided in her absence that she wasn't coping well enough to competently continue as director of Blenheim House. The decision devastated Cindy as she lived and breathed her job. As a parting gesture, Cindy received a payout. Given that she had worked in her specialist role at Blenheim House for 13 years, the company also provided funds for Cindy to upgrade her nursing skills so she could return to work as a hospital ward nurse. Not long after, she took a job at Richmond General Hospital on award for patients who had recently been discharged from the ICU but were not well enough to return home. This job had Cindy returning to shift work and working long hours.
1986年中期，辛迪去了德国探望并在那里工作的哥哥罗杰（Roger）并留宿。回来后，请了六个月病假的辛迪感觉身体状况足以重返工作岗位。她立即被要求辞职。在她缺席期间，人们已经决定她无法很好地胜任布伦海姆大楼主管的职务。这个决定让辛迪痛不欲生，因为她全身心热爱着她的工作。作为离别姿态，辛迪得到了一笔赔偿金。鉴于她在布伦海姆大楼的专业岗位上工作了13年，公司还为辛迪提供资金提升护理技能，以便她能作为医院病房护士重返工作岗位。不久之后，她在列治文综合医院找到了一份工作，负责刚从重症监护室（ICU）出院但病情尚未完全恢复回家的患者病区。这份工作让辛迪重新开始倒班并长时间工作。
She had further difficulty sleeping, relying more on medications such as diazepam and lost weight, often feeling too anxious to weight. Her weight plummeted to 44 kilograms. At the behest of her psychiatrist who saw Cindy fortnightly after her release from the psychiatric hospital, Cindy began keeping a private journal. The psychiatrist hoped it would help if Cindy recorded everything and reflected on her thoughts. From the book about Cindy by Neil Hall, one entry dated April 30, 1988, read, Gotta hang up call about half an hour after getting home. Don't know if it's that or what, but I feel kind of jittery. I hope there aren't any more over the next few days as that seems to have been a pattern before my house was broken into each time.
她再次遇到睡眠困难，更加依赖地西泮等药物并体重下降，常常感到过于焦虑而无法称体重。她的体重骤降至44公斤。在精神科医生（在辛迪出院后每两周看一次她）的要求下，辛迪开始写私人日记。精神科医生希望如果辛迪记录下一切并反思自己的想法会有所帮助。根据尼尔·霍尔（Neil Hall）关于辛迪的书，一篇日期为1988年4月30日的日记写道：“到家大约半小时后接到一个挂断的电话。不知道是因为这个还是什么，但我感觉有点神经质。我希望接下来的几天里不要再有了，因为这似乎是我每次家遭入室盗窃前的一种模式。”
Maybe I'll take a taxi to work on Monday night so it doesn't look like the house is empty. Christ, I'm so sick of this. I'm so tired of living in fear. I'm so bloody tired, period. I'm tired of being tired. Cindy used her journal to express her anger towards the various people in her life that had left her in despair. Her parents for her strict upbringing. Roy make peace for his control over her while they were together.
“也许我会在星期一晚上坐出租车去上班，这样看起来家里就不空了。天哪，我太厌烦这个了。我厌倦了生活在恐惧之中。句号，我他妈的太累了。我厌倦了疲惫。”辛迪在日记中表达了她对生活中那些让她陷入绝望的各种人的愤怒。她的父母对她管教严格。罗伊·梅克皮斯在他们在一起时对她的控制。
And the Vancouver and Richmond police, who whilst they assured Cindy they were doing everything to catch her assailant, she felt were brushing her off. On October 9, 1988, Roy make peace was sitting in his apartment in Kitsulano, Vancouver, 15 kilometres north of Cindy's house in Richmond. Two men approached the main entrance and rang the intercom at the Secure apartment building. Roy didn't recognise them, so ignored their buzzing. Several minutes later, he could hear noises at his apartment door. Roy looked out of the peephole but couldn't see anyone, they were just out of view. He soon realised it was the two young men who had been outside moments before, someone else having let them into the building. Roy heard one say, you go down, I'll wait here until he comes out.
还有温哥华和列治文的警察，虽然他们向辛迪保证他们正在尽一切努力抓捕袭击者，但她觉得他们在敷衍她。1988年10月9日，罗伊·梅克皮斯正坐在他位于温哥华基茨拉诺（Kitsilano）的公寓里，这里距离辛迪在列治文的家以北15公里。两个男人走近主入口，按了戒备森严的公寓大楼的对讲机。罗伊不认识他们，因此忽略了他们的蜂鸣声。几分钟后，他听到他的公寓门传来响动。罗伊透过猫眼往外看，但看不到任何人，他们刚好在视野之外。他很快意识到是刚才在外面那两个年轻男子，有人把他们放进了大楼。罗伊听到一个人说：“你下去，我在这等他出来。”
After staying outside for about an hour, both men left. Roy, although distressed by the incident, did not contact the police. His treatment by detectives over the attacks on his ex-wife made him distrustful and he wanted as little to do with authorities as possible. Roy decided instead that from now on, any visitors to his apartment would need to buzz on the intercom using Morse code for the letter R, so Roy knew it was safe to let them in. Two days after the strange man at his door, Roy was checking his answering machine when a 12 second message chilled him. A low, snarling voice said, Sunday, dead, meet, soon. Roy panicked, thinking it was from the two young men who were at his door the previous Sunday. He replayed the message. On the second listen, he realised that the caller wasn't saying Sunday, they were saying Cindy.
在外面待了一个多小时后，这两个人离开了几。罗伊虽然对这起事件感到不安，但没有联系警方。侦探对前妻遇袭事件的处理方式让他不信任警方，他希望尽可能少地与当局打交道。罗伊决定，从今以后，任何来他公寓的访客都需要在对讲机上按字母R的摩斯密码，以便罗伊知道放他们进来是安全的。在那个奇怪的男人出现在他门外的两天后，罗伊正在检查他的答录机，一条12秒的留言让他不寒而栗。一个低沉、咆哮的声音说：“周日，死，见，快。”罗伊惊慌失措，以为这是上周日在他门外的两个年轻人留下的。他重播了留言。听第二遍时，他意识到打电话的人说的不是“周日”，他们说的是“辛迪”。
Sunday, dead, meet, soon. Roy believed that the caller was the person who had been harassing Cindy for the past six years. The next day, as he checked his answering machine again, Roy had another message. This one, in the same growling tone, said, Hey man, more smack, more downers, another grand after we waste the cunt. No more deal. Roy sent a copy of the threatening messages to his lawyer, believing that he was being framed. In response, Roy's lawyer told him to forward the tapes to the Vancouver police chief. Roy declined and did not tell Cindy about the calls.
“辛迪，死，见，快。”罗伊相信打电话的人就是过去六年里一直骚扰辛迪的那个人。第二天，当他再次检查答录机时，罗伊又收到了一条留言。这条留言用同样的低沉咆哮语调说：“嘿，老兄，更多的毒品，更多的镇静剂，在我们做掉那个婊子后还有一千块。不再做交易了。”罗伊将威胁留言的副本发给他的律师，认为自己被陷害了。作为回应，罗伊的律师告诉他将磁带转交给温哥华警察局长。罗伊拒绝了，也没有把这些电话告诉辛迪。
Later that month, on October 26, Cindy finished work at 8.30pm after a 13 hour shift. She was due to clock off an hour earlier, but a patient on her ward died and Cindy stayed back to complete the required paperwork. Extremely saddened and dejected at the loss of her patient, Cindy pulled into her garage and waited with the engine and lights off. This was a habit she had gotten into to make sure everything was quiet and safe at her house before she exited her car. As Cindy got out, she noticed a man standing at the rear of her blue Chevrolet citation. Wearing a ski mask, the man grabbed Cindy and put a knife to her neck. He said that he would kill her. It was then that Cindy realized there was another man, his face also concealed by a ski mask. Cindy tried to fight off her attackers, but a needle was pushed into her right arm.
同月晚些时候，即10月26日，辛迪在值完13小时的班后于晚上8点30分下班。她本该提前一小时打卡下班，但病区里的一名患者去世了，辛迪留下来完成所需的 paperwork（文书工作）。由于失去患者而感到极其悲伤和沮丧，辛迪将车开进车库，在关闭发动机和车灯的情况下等待着。这是她养成的一个习惯，为的是在下车前确保家里一切安静安全。当辛迪下车时，她注意到她的蓝色雪佛兰休旅车（Citations）后面站着一个男人。戴着滑雪面具，这个男人抓住辛迪并把刀架在她的脖子上。他说他会杀了她。就在那时，辛迪意识到还有另一个男人，他的脸也被滑雪面具遮住。辛迪试图反抗袭击者，但一根针被扎进了她的右臂。
The silent alarm registered to Cindy James was received approximately two and a half hours later by Ozzy Caban Security Company. A police officer responded shortly after midnight, parking his car outside Cindy's house. Everything was silent. As the officer walked up Cindy's driveway, he noticed the interior light of her car in the open garage was on. He found Cindy lying in the driver's seat naked from the waist down. Her pantyhose were pulled down around her ankles. Her legs were protruding from the car door and her hands had been tied behind her back with a black nylon stocking. Another was tied around her neck.
大约两个半小时后，奥兹·卡班保安公司（Ozzy Caban Security Company）收到了注册在辛迪·詹姆斯名下的无声警报。一名警官在午夜过后不久赶到现场，将车停在辛迪家外面。万籁俱寂。当这名警官走上辛迪的车道时，他注意到开着车库门的车内灯亮着。他发现辛迪躺在驾驶座上，腰部以下赤裸。她的连裤袜被拉到了脚踝周围。她的双腿从车门伸出来，双手被一根黑色尼龙长筒袜反绑在背后。另一根长筒袜缠在她的脖子上。
In one of her hands was the alarm device. Cindy's mouth was covered with gray duct tape and crusted blood formed around her nostrils. Her skin was cold. Unable to find a pulse, the police officer radioed for backup stating that Cindy was deceased. A responding officer arrived and heard Cindy wheeze. Realizing she was still alive, the officers worked to free her from her restraints. She was taken immediately to Richmond General Hospital for treatment in the ICU, where some of the nurses recognized Cindy as their colleague. The next day, Cindy fell into a coma.
她的一只手里拿着报警装置。辛迪的嘴被灰色胶带封住，鼻孔周围结了血痂。她的皮肤很冷。由于找不到脉搏，这名警官用无线电呼叫支援，称辛迪已经死亡。一名赶来的警官到达并听到辛迪发出呼噜声。意识到她还活着，警官们努力帮她解开束缚。她被立即送往列治文综合医院重症监护室接受治疗，在那里一些护士认出辛迪是她们的同事。第二天，辛迪陷入昏迷。
Fearing a brain injury, a neurologist had Cindy transferred to a second hospital. There, she was intubated and had a number of brain scans. They revealed no permanent damage. When Cindy regained consciousness, she was questioned extensively as Richmond police investigated the crime scene. Four export A brand cigarette butts were found near Cindy's car as well as a Kleenex tissue with small spots of blood. Cindy slowly recovered and was discharged from hospital. Richmond detectives determined a pattern in the Cindy James case. There would be periods where nothing occurred and then the phone calls and threatening letters began almost as a warning to Cindy to be on guard for a physical attack.
由于担心脑损伤，神经科医生将辛迪转送到第二家医院。在那里，她接受了插管并做了多次脑部扫描。扫描显示没有永久性损伤。当辛迪恢复意识时，她受到了广泛盘问，因为列治文警方正在调查犯罪现场。在辛迪的车附近发现了四个“出口A”（Export A）品牌烟头以及带有少量血迹的克林内斯（Kleenex）纸巾。辛迪慢慢康复并出院。列治文侦探在辛迪·詹姆斯案中发现了一种模式。会有一些时期什么都没有发生，然后电话和威胁信开始出现，几乎像是在警告辛迪对人身袭击保持警惕。
An attack would then occur and then the threats would cease for a short period of time. Friends and family of Cindy believed that her attacker wanted to torment and drive Cindy insane from the attacks rather than kill her. They cited that the attacker already had multiple opportunities in which they could have killed Cindy, but hadn't. In response on April 3, 1989, Richmond authorities went about installing permanent surveillance at Cindy's house. Setbacks, including equipment failure and technical problems, made this a frustrating and time-consuming endeavor. However, they were confident the assailant would be caught. It was just a matter of watching and waiting. On May 25, Cindy went for coffee with the nursing friend Diane Yong. It was her first day off of five from the hospital. Together they discussed their travel dreams and Cindy happily told Diane how the attacks against her seemed to have quietened down of late.
随后会发生袭击，然后威胁会停止短时间。辛迪的朋友和家人认为，她的袭击者是想通过袭击折磨辛迪并把她逼疯，而不是杀死她。他们列举说袭击者以前已经有多次可以杀死辛迪的机会，但却没有动手。作为回应，1989年4月3日，列治文当局着手在辛迪家安装永久监控。设备故障和技术问题等挫折使这成为一项令人沮丧且耗时的任务。然而，他们相信袭击者会被抓获。这只是观察和等待的问题。5月25日，辛迪和护理界朋友黛安·杨（Diane Yong）去喝咖啡。这是她从医院连休五天的第一天。他们一起讨论了旅游梦想，辛迪开心地告诉黛安，针对她的袭击最近似乎平静下来了。
Later that afternoon, Cindy went to pick up her paycheck. She had a friendly chat with payroll clerk Tammy Carmen about all the things she planned to do on the remaining four days off she had from work, including attending a birthday party. Tammy commented on Cindy's appearance, telling her how gorgeous she looked in her pink blouse, burgundy pants and blue suede jacket. Cindy explained that she had just had a makeover at a beauty salon in the mall. Tammy hadn't recalled seeing Cindy that bubbly in a long time. At approximately nine that night, Tom and Agnes Woodcock arrived at Cindy's place to play bridge. They were confused to find Cindy wasn't home as they had organized the late-night card game only hours earlier. Tom and Agnes drove around the main streets of Richmond, hoping to spot Cindy's car on the road.
那天下午晚些时候，辛迪去领取她的薪水。她与工资核算员塔米·卡门（Tammy Carmen）亲切交谈，谈论她计划在剩余四天假期间做的所有事情，包括参加生日派对。塔米对辛迪的外表发表了评论，告诉她穿着粉红色衬衫、酒红色裤子和蓝色麂皮夹克看起来多么华丽。辛迪解释说她刚在商场的美术沙龙做了个新造型。塔米记不起很久没有看到辛迪这么充满活力了。那天晚上9点左右，汤姆和艾格尼丝·伍德科克到达辛迪家打桥牌。他们惊讶地发现辛迪不在家，因为他们几个小时前才安排好深夜打牌。汤姆和艾格尼丝开车绕着列治文的主街道行驶，希望能在大街上看到辛迪的车。
As they drove past the Blundell shopping center car park, Agnes saw Cindy's powder blue Chevrolet citation parked near the bank of Montreal. Pulling into the near-deserted car park, they examined the vehicle. It was locked. Cindy's keys were visible on the front seat. A small trickle of blood ran down the driver's side door. Cindy was nowhere to be found. Police investigated the scene. Inside the car, two paper Safeway bags containing groceries were found on the front passenger seat with Cindy's black purse wedged between them. Her purse contained a total of $2.77.
当他们开车经过布伦德尔（Blundell）购物中心停车场时，艾格尼丝看到辛迪浅蓝色的雪佛兰休旅车停在蒙特利尔银行附近。他们把车开进几乎空无一人的停车场，检查了这辆车。车是锁着的。辛迪的钥匙在前座上清晰可见。驾驶员工门上流下一小股血迹。辛迪不知所踪。警方对现场进行了调查。在车内，前排乘客座椅上发现两个装有杂货的纸质西夫韦（Safeway）袋子，辛迪的黑色钱包夹在它们中间。她的钱包里总共有2.77美元。
A further two grocery bags were found in the floor well of the passenger seat. On the back seats, lay two Sears bags containing a croquet set and wrapping paper. Underneath Cindy's car was her bank card with an ATM transaction receipt wrapped around it. The receipt indicated that Cindy had deposited her paycheck at $7.58 earlier that night. The position of Cindy's car concerned her friend Agnes. Cindy preferred to park as close to the bank's exterior ATM machine as possible, as this meant that she didn't have to walk far from her car at night. Agnes knew that Cindy would wait if needed for the closest car space to become available. At 3.16am, two constables arrived at Roy's mate's apartment for questioning.
在乘客座位的脚坑里又发现了两个杂货袋。后座上放着两个西尔斯（Sears）袋子，里面装着克球戏套装和包装纸。辛迪的车底是她的银行卡，上面缠着一张ATM交易收据。收据显示辛迪当晚早些时候在7点58分存了薪水。辛迪汽车的位置让她的朋友艾格尼丝感到担忧。辛迪更愿意把车停得尽可能靠近银行外部的ATM机，因为这意味着她晚上不用从车走很远。艾格尼丝知道如果需要的话辛迪会等待最近的车位空出来。凌晨3点16分，两名警员抵达罗伊·梅克皮斯的公寓进行盘问。
Roy initially refused to let them in, appearing frightened and argumentative. Eventually, he obliged, telling the officers that the reason for his behaviour was that he was fearful for his life. He now slept with a rifle beside his bed after getting numerous hang-up calls and phone messages. Whilst talking to Roy, the officers took note of his apartment. The rooms were cluttered and in disarray. His bed appeared slept in. Roy gave an alibi for the night before, explaining he went cycling to a market with a friend. It was then that officers told Roy about Cindy's disappearance. He teared up and whispered,
罗伊最初拒绝让他们进门，显得害怕且好辩。最终，他照办了，告诉警官他表现失常的原因是他害怕自己的生命安全。在接到无数挂断电话和电话留言后，他现在睡觉时床边放着一把步枪。在与罗伊交谈时，警官们注意到了他的公寓。房间杂乱无章。他的床看起来有人睡过。罗伊为前一天晚上提供了不在场证明，解释说他和朋友骑自行车去了市场。就在那时，警官们把辛迪失踪的消息告诉了罗伊。他流下了眼泪，低声说道：
My God, she's dead. A foot search commenced in the Richmond area with sniffer dogs, but there was no sign of Cindy. Her car underwent forensic testing. Only Cindy's fingerprints were uncovered on the vehicle. The blood on the door handle matched her blood type. Using the Bank of Montreal records, police identified the customers who used the exterior ATM 15 minutes before and after Cindy. Barry Leroy, who used the machine three minutes after Cindy, told officers he saw a blonde woman resembling Cindy walk in front of his car in a diagonal direction across the parking lot. She was heading northeast, away from the shopping centre. At the time, there were about six or eight other cars parked in the lot.
“天哪，她死了。”列治文地区随即展开了搜寻行动，有搜救犬参与，但没有辛迪的踪迹。她的车进行了法医检测。车上只发现了辛迪的指纹。门把手上的血迹与她的血型相符。利用蒙特利尔银行的记录，警方确认了在辛迪之后15分钟内使用外部ATM机的客户。巴里·勒鲁瓦（Barry Leroy）在辛迪之后三分钟使用该机器，他告诉警官他看到一个长相酷似辛迪的金发女郎在停车场呈对角线方向走到他的车前。她正朝东北方向走去，远离购物中心。当时，停车场里大约停着其他六到八辆车。
Barry said that the woman was the only person he saw, although looking at a photo, he couldn't be positive it was Cindy. As the search continued, Cindy's father Otto travelled from his home on Vancouver Island and stayed in Cindy's house to await any news of his daughter. Distraught, he offered to provide 500 military men to help search for Cindy. This offer was declined by the police, who assured him they were looking everywhere for his daughter. Five days passed with no signs of Cindy. Her face was splashed across newspapers as police urged witnesses to come forward. Staff Sergeant Ron Darun told the Richmond Review that they were baffled, explaining that Cindy, quote, just kind of floated up into the sky like Houdini.
巴里说那个女人是他在现场看到的唯一一个人，尽管看了一张照片，他不能肯定那是辛迪。随着搜寻的继续，辛迪的父亲奥托（Otto）从温哥华岛的家中赶来，住在辛迪家里等待女儿的任何消息。心烦意乱的他主动提出提供500名军人来帮忙搜寻辛迪。这一提议被警方拒绝了，警方保证他们正在到处寻找他的女儿。五天过去了，没有辛迪的踪迹。她的脸登上了各大报纸，警方敦促目击者挺身而出。高级警长罗恩·达伦（Ron Darun）对《列治文评论报》（Richmond Review）表示，他们对此感到迷惑不解，并解释说辛迪“就像胡迪尼一样不知怎么飘上了天空”。
Flight and other transportation records were checked with no indications that Cindy had left the area. Her family believed that Cindy had been abducted. Otto Hack told the province that before his daughter disappeared, she called a friend. Cindy said to her, Some people may think I'm paranoid, but I have a feeling I've been followed all week. This was in direct contrast to others who saw Cindy that day, saying she was bright, bubbly, and the happiest she'd been in a long time. The search of Cindy's house revealed nothing out of the ordinary, aside from four bottles of prescription sedatives and nine small boxes of an over-the-counter sedative, both of which Cindy used to get to sleep. It became apparent to detectives that she was hoarding tablets.
警方检查了航班和其他交通记录，没有迹象表明辛迪离开过该地区。她的家人相信辛迪被绑架了。奥托·哈克告诉《省报》（The Province），在女儿失踪前，她给一个朋友打了电话。辛迪对她说：“有些人可能认为我有被害妄想，但我有一种感觉，我一整周都被人跟踪了。”这与当天看到辛迪的人的说法形成鲜明对比，后者称她开朗、充满活力，是她很长时间以来最开心的时候。对辛迪房子的搜查没有发现任何异常，除了四瓶处方镇静剂和九小盒非处方镇静剂，这两种药辛迪都用来入睡。侦探们发现她在囤积药片。
Her family also found another 19 bottles of prescription medication hidden in her home. They made a list of all the drugs which totaled 900 pills before flushing them down the toilet. In addition, her family also found in a spare room a kit containing a needle and syringe, an intravenous cannula, and saline solution. In the days after Cindy's disappearance, someone phoned the office where Cindy's life insurance policy was held. Claiming to be Cindy's father, the male caller requested some information on the policy. The secretary said that they would have to visit the office personally to discuss the matter. The line went dead. Cindy's father denied making the call. The secretary told police that the caller sounded older and had a slight accent.
她的家人还在她家中发现了另外19瓶藏起来的处方药。他们列出了所有药物的清单，总共900粒药丸，然后把它们冲进马桶。此外，她的家人还在客房里发现了一个急救包，里面有一根针和注射器、一根静脉套管以及生理盐水。在辛迪失踪后的几天里，有人打电话到辛迪人寿保险单所在的办公室。自称是辛迪父亲的男来电者索取了保单的一些信息。秘书说他们必须亲自去办公室讨论此事。电话挂断了。辛迪的父亲否认打过这个电话。秘书告诉警方，来电者听起来年纪较大，带有轻微的口音。
June 8, 1989 marked exactly two weeks after Cindy James's disappearance. One and a half kilometers from the Blundell Road shopping centre, a municipal works crew continued their job repairing part of a pavement on Blundell Road. At 10am, worker Gordon Starchuk needed to urinate. The busy road offered no privacy, but the house behind him was abandoned. Making his way down the side of the property, Gordon passed the heavily graffitied exterior and ventured onto a vacant lot behind the house. Out of the corner of his eye, Gordon saw a pink blouse and blonde hair. Initially thinking that a woman was sleeping on the ground, he realised this was not the case as he ventured closer. The woman was lying on her right side, partly on a blue suede jacket, and was wearing burgundy pants and one shoe.
1989年6月8日正好是辛迪·詹姆斯失踪两周。距离布伦德尔路购物中心1.5公里处，一个市政工程队继续他们在布伦德尔路修路面部分的工作。上午10点，工人戈登·斯塔丘克（Gordon Starchuk）需要小便。繁忙的马路无法提供隐私，但他身后的房子是一栋废弃的房屋。戈登顺着房产的一侧走去，走过了布满涂鸦的外墙，冒险进入房子后面的一片空地。用眼角余光，戈登看到了一件粉红色衬衫和金发。最初以为一个女人睡在地上，当他走近时，他意识到并非如此。这个女人右侧身躺着，部分压在一件蓝色麂皮夹克上，穿着酒红色裤子和一只鞋。
The other shoe was lying nearby. It was apparent the woman had been dead for some time. Her face was completely blackened from exposure and decomposition. Her wrists and ankles were tied behind her back. Around her neck was a black nylon stocking. It was Cindy James. Police secured the crime scene while onlookers gathered on the side of the road. Detectives interviewed locals, none of whom reported anything suspicious in the past two weeks.
另一只鞋掉在附近。显然这个女人已经死去一段时间了。她的脸因暴露和腐烂而完全变黑。她的手腕和脚踝被反绑在背后。她的脖子上缠着一根黑色尼龙长筒袜。正是辛迪·詹姆斯。警方封锁了犯罪现场，围观群众聚集在马路边。侦探们采访了当地人，没有人报告过去两周有任何可疑情况。
At the time, a squatter was living in a van behind the lot, only five metres from where Cindy was found. Even though he cooked his meals over a fireside less than two metres from where Cindy's body lay, he recalled nothing out of the ordinary in the past two weeks and had certainly not noticed Cindy lying there. The abandoned house, with broken windows and spray-painted messages including the word devil, 666 and swastikas, was a hangout spot for a group of local teens. It contained no evidence that it was ever accessed by Cindy or her attackers. Although there were some bloodstaining and cuts to Cindy's blouse, there were no injuries to her skin underneath. Investigators were expecting the cause of Cindy's death to be strangulation.
当时，一个流浪汉住在空地后面的一辆面包车里，距离发现辛迪的地方只有五米。尽管他在距离辛迪尸体躺着不到两米的地方生火做饭，但他回忆说过去两周没有任何异常，当然也没有注意到辛迪躺在那里。这栋破窗户、喷涂着“魔鬼”、“666”和“卐”字等信息的废弃房屋是当地一群青少年的聚会场所。这里没有证据表明辛迪或她的袭击者曾进入过这里。虽然辛迪的衬衫上有血迹和割破痕迹，但下面的皮肤没有受伤。调查人员原以为辛迪的死因是勒死。
However, this was not the case. There were no injuries consistent with strangulation. Three millilitres of blood was taken for a toxicology screening in the hope it would provide some answers as to how Cindy died. Days later, a message appeared on a fuel tank that lay beside the abandoned house. In orange spray paint, the sentence, some bitch died here, was written with a line extending from the fuel tank to where Cindy's body was found. Whoever was responsible was never identified. A month later, Otto and Tilly Hack as well as Cindy's siblings met with police. Cindy's family waited, expecting an update.
然而，事实并非如此。没有与勒死一致的伤情。提取了三毫升血液进行毒理学筛查，希望能提供一些关于辛迪如何死去的答案。几天后，废弃房屋旁的一个油箱上出现了一条信息。用橙色喷漆写着“某个婊子死在这里”这句话，一条线从油箱延伸到发现辛迪尸体的地方。肇事者从未被查明。一个月后，奥托和蒂莉·哈克（Tilly Hack）以及辛迪的兄弟姐妹与警方会面。辛迪的家人等待着，期待着最新进展。
They were told that the Royal Canadian Mounted Police were no longer investigating Cindy's murder. They were confident her death was a suicide. An inquest into Cindy James's death was held in February 1990. The toxicology report showed that Cindy had eight different drugs in her body, including floresepam, diazepam and morphine. The massive drug overdose, particularly of floresepam and morphine, was concluded to have caused her death. Over the seven years prior to the final attack, Cindy had made a total of nearly 100 reports to police departments. These included hang-up calls, threatening letters, destroyed property, physical attacks, three separate fires and three occasions of dead cats being found on her property. On two of these occasions, the cats had been strangled.
他们被告知加拿大皇家骑警不再调查辛迪的谋杀案。他们确信她的死是自杀。1990年2月对辛迪·詹姆斯的死因进行了死因研讯。毒理学报告显示辛迪体内有八种不同的药物，包括氟西泮（floresepam）、地西泮和吗啡。得出的结论是，大量药物过量，特别是氟西泮和吗啡，导致了她的死亡。在最后一次袭击前的七年里，辛迪总共向警察局报案近100次。其中包括挂断电话、威胁信、财产被毁、人身袭击、三次独立的火灾以及在其物业上发现三起死猫的事件。其中两次，猫被勒死。
As time went by, suspicions grew, but not towards anyone in Cindy's life. Most, but not all of the police investigating the attacks, started to believe Cindy was responsible. Cindy's friends and family were adamant that she had been the victim of a sadistic stalker. Five jurors were tasked with having to decide whether Cindy was the victim of foul play, ended her own life, or perpetrated the final attack herself and accidentally went too far. One of the first to give evidence was Vancouver Constable Valon Woolacott. Constable Valon Woolacott arrived at Cindy's home on January 27, 1983, just over six years before Cindy went missing. He had been dispatched to her home after the first physical attack on Cindy, in which friend Agnes Woodcock had found her in a basement stairwell with a black nylon stocking around her neck. After talking with Cindy, who told him of how she had been attacked in the garage of her home, Constable Woolacott conducted a search of Cindy's house.
随着时间的推移，怀疑声越来越大，但不是针对辛迪生活中的任何人。调查这些袭击的大多数（但不是全部）警察开始相信辛迪应当承担责任。辛迪的朋友和家人坚信她是虐待狂跟踪者的受害人。五名陪审员的任务是决定辛迪是谋杀案的受害者，还是自己结束了生命，亦或是自己策划了最后一次袭击却不小心过了头。最早作证的人之一是温哥华警员瓦隆·伍拉科特（Valon Woolacott）。瓦隆·伍拉科特警员于1983年1月27日抵达辛迪家，也就是辛迪失踪前六年多。在辛迪遭遇第一次人身袭击后，他被派往她家，当时朋友艾格尼丝·伍德科克在地下室楼梯间发现她脖子上套着一根黑色尼龙长筒袜。在与向他讲述自己如何在自家车库遭遇袭击的辛迪交谈后，伍拉科特警员对辛迪的家进行了搜查。
Everything seemed well kept and in order. Cindy's house was full of indoor plants that were thriving under her care and attention. The garage light was working, unlike Cindy had claimed. Furthermore, there was no indication of a struggle. The boxes that Cindy said she had been moving were piled neatly in a corner. The only sign that an attack had taken place was a mark of blood on one of the boxes that looked like a smudged thumbprint. When he walked past the bathroom, Constable Woolacott stopped. There was fresh blood on the bathroom counter and a spray of blood on the sink and mirror.
一切看起来都保养得很好，井然有序。辛迪的家里摆满了室内植物，在她的精心照料下长势良好。车库灯亮着，这与辛迪的说法相反。此外，没有挣扎的迹象。辛迪说她一直在搬动的箱子整齐地堆在一个角落里。袭击发生过的唯一迹象是其中一个箱子上的血迹，看起来像是一个模糊的拇指印。当他路过浴室时，伍拉科特警员停了下来。浴室柜台上血迹斑斑，洗手池和镜子上有喷溅的血迹。
Cindy had never mentioned any altercation occurring in the bathroom. Given this discrepancy, Cindy James agreed to take a polygraph test regarding the night of the attack. She was asked if she had inflicted the cuts to herself and tied the nylon stocking around her own neck on the night of the attack. Cindy replied, No. The polygraph indicated she was being deceptive. The test was repeated another day. Again, Cindy failed. When given the results, Cindy grabbed the polygraph operator's arm and said, I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. Detective David Boyer-Smith thought that even though she had failed two polygraphs, the fact that Cindy was incredibly nervous and emotional may have influenced the results.
辛迪从未提过浴室发生过任何争吵。鉴于这一出入，辛迪·詹姆斯同意就袭击当晚接受测谎仪测试。她被问及她在袭击当晚是否自己制造了割伤并将尼龙长筒袜绑在自己脖子上。辛迪回答说：“没有。”测谎仪显示她在说谎。测试在另一天重复进行。辛迪再次未通过。拿到结果时，辛迪抓住测谎操作员的手臂说：“我太抱歉了。我太抱歉了。”侦探大卫·博耶-史密斯（David Boyer-Smith）认为，尽管她两次测谎未通过，但辛迪异常紧张和情绪激动的事实可能影响了结果。
Cindy could not recall the night's events without breaking down and becoming histrionic. He asked Cindy to come clean and she changed her version of events, telling the detective the attack had indeed occurred in the house, not in the garage as she had previously claimed. She told him that she had been too scared to tell the truth as the attacker had threatened to harm her family. Vancouver police constable Keel Acoma responded to the emergency call from Ozzie Caban when he found Cindy on the floor with the paring knife through her hand on January 30, 1984. Acoma told the inquest that the blood on the kitchen floor where Cindy claimed the attack had initially taken place was smeared in a circular pattern as though an attempt had been made to clean it. He also noted that Ozzie Caban had been forced to kick down the front door after both doors to the house were locked. The coroner asked him if he had ever come across a crime scene before where the assailant had wiped up blood and then locked the door behind them before leaving the scene. Constable Acoma replied, The door, yes, but not cleaned up blood.
辛迪无法回忆当晚的事情而不崩溃和歇斯底里。他要求辛迪坦白，她改变了事件版本，告诉侦探袭击确实发生在屋里，而不是像她以前宣称的那样在车库里。她告诉他，她太害怕而不敢说实话，因为袭击者威胁要伤害她的家人。温哥华警员基尔·阿科马（Keel Acoma）在1984年1月30日回应了奥兹·卡班的紧急呼叫，当时他在地板上发现了辛迪，手里插着一把削皮刀。阿科马在研讯中说，辛迪称袭击最初发生的厨房地板上的血迹呈圆形涂抹状，就像有人试图清理它一样。他还指出，由于房子的两扇门都锁着，奥兹·卡班被迫踹开前门。验尸官问他是否曾遇到过犯罪现场，袭击者擦去血迹并在离开现场前锁上门。阿科马警员回答：“门，是的，但血迹没有被清理过。”
Cindy's family and friends could not believe that authorities suspected Cindy of stabbing her own hand in the frenzied attack, but more testimony implicating Cindy was yet to come. Detective Gary Foster recounted one of the arson attacks to Cindy's basement on August 21, 1985. He went to Cindy's house after the fire had been extinguished and along with another detective went about searching for evidence. The basement could either be accessed from an interior door or from a louvered window that opened to the outside. Given that there was no evidence of an intruder in the house, the detectives focused on the basement window. Divided into three panes of glass, the window opened outwards, making it difficult for someone to crawl through. The sills were covered in thick dust and cobwebs which were undisturbed. One of the detectives tried to see if it were possible to gain entry via the window, covering himself in dust and leaving a trail of fingerprints in the process.
辛迪的家人和朋友不敢相信当局竟然怀疑辛迪在狂乱的袭击中刺伤了自己的手，但更多暗示辛迪涉案的证词还在后头。侦探加里·福斯特（Gary Foster）回忆了1985年8月21日对辛迪地下室的纵火袭击之一。大火扑灭后，他去了辛迪家，与其他侦探一起寻找证据。地下室可以通过内部门或通往外面的百叶窗式窗户进入。鉴于没有屋内有入侵者的证据，侦探们将重点放在地下室窗户上。窗户分成三块玻璃，向外打开，使人很难爬进去。窗台布满厚厚的灰尘和蜘蛛网，没有受到干扰。其中一名侦探试图看是否有可能通过窗户进入，在这个过程中自己沾满灰尘并留下一串指纹。
The detectives suggested that whoever started the fire may have thrown lit paper through the window, but arson investigators later concluded that the fire had been lit in six different places from inside. A roll of toilet paper from the basement bathroom and a reader's digest magazine had been used to set fire to a towel, subsequently igniting the basement bathroom. Detective Carol Halliday joined the investigation after this attack. From the minute she spoke to Cindy, she believed that Cindy was acting and carrying out the attacks herself. She argued that Cindy had gotten away with it because the male investigators overseeing the case were so enamoured by Cindy's charm and good looks. Detective Halliday wanted to have Cindy charged with public mischief and arson. However, her superiors declined to do so, in concern for the effect it would have on her mental health. Cindy was also suspected of lighting the fire on April 19, 1986, when friends Tom and Agnes Woodcock were staying over.
侦探们暗示，纵火者可能是通过窗户扔了点燃的纸，但纵火调查人员后来得出结论，火是从里面六个不同地方点燃的。地下室浴室的卫生卷纸和一本《读者文摘》（Reader's Digest）杂志被用来点燃一条毛巾，随后引燃了地下室浴室。侦探卡罗尔·哈利迪（Carol Halliday）在此次袭击后加入了调查。从她跟辛迪说话的第一分钟起，她就相信辛迪是在演戏，并亲自实施了这些袭击。她辩称辛迪之所以能逃脱惩罚，是因为负责该案的男性调查员如此迷恋辛迪的魅力和美貌。哈利迪侦探想以公众恶作剧和纵火罪起诉辛迪。然而，她的上司出于对这对她心理健康影响的担忧而拒绝这样做。1986年4月19日，当朋友汤姆和艾格尼丝·伍德科克留宿时，辛迪也被怀疑点燃了火。
Investigators noticed that even though the fire had started in the early hours of the morning, Cindy's bed appeared to have not been slept in. This implied she had been up all night. The fire started amongst the bookcase containing memories of Cindy's marriage to Roy, further adding to the speculation that Cindy set the blaze herself. Tom Woodcock disagreed, remembering the strange man he had seen outside of Cindy's house soon after who had run down the road. This man was never identified. Roy Makepeace, hounded by detectives as the prime suspect for years during the attacks on Cindy, was finally able to have his say at the inquest. The police conceded that there was not one shred of evidence to link him to any of the assaults. Roy added that he had been in South Africa on the night of one of the arsons. Cindy, not aware of this, had told detectives she believed Roy had lit the fire.
调查人员注意到，尽管火灾发生在清晨，但辛迪的床看起来好像没有睡过。这意味着她整晚都没睡。火灾是从存放辛迪与罗伊婚姻回忆的书架中燃起的，这进一步增加了辛迪自己纵火的猜测。汤姆·伍德科克不同意这种说法，他记得不久后他在辛迪家外面看到那个沿路跑开的奇怪男人。这个男人从未被查明。罗伊·梅克皮斯在辛迪遇袭期间多年来一直遭到侦探们的搜捕和盘问，终于在研讯中得以发声。警方承认，没有一丝证据将他与任何袭击联系起来。罗伊补充说，其中一次纵火的当晚他在南非。辛迪对此并不知情，曾告诉侦探她相信是罗伊点燃了火。
In an emotion-filled testimony, Roy broke down when describing their blissful years as newlyweds. He denounced Cindy's story of a cabin murder in the Gulf Islands revealed under hypnotherapy as sheer fiction. Cindy had failed to disclose that her sister Melanie was also on board the pacemaker and witnessed none of the traumatic events Cindy described. While admitting to slapping Cindy twice in their marriage, he clarified that Cindy did not require reconstructive breast surgery after a particularly savage assault. She had an elective breast augmentation procedure. Explaining the years prior to her death in the book The Deaths of Cindy James by Neil Hall, Roy Makepeace said with a tinge of anguish in his voice. It just went from bad to worse to impossible to death. I did everything possible to be supporting, comforting, sympathetic. She was a quiet person who would hold a lot of things in.
在一场充满情感的证词中，罗伊在描述他们作为新婚夫妇的幸福岁月时情绪崩溃。他谴责辛迪在催眠状态下透露的海湾群岛小屋谋杀案纯属虚构。辛迪未能透露她的妹妹梅兰妮也在船上，并且没有目睹辛迪描述的任何创伤事件。在承认在婚姻期间扇过辛迪两巴掌的同时，他澄清说，在一次特别野蛮的袭击后，辛迪并没有接受乳房重建手术。她做的是选择性隆胸手术。尼尔·霍尔在《辛迪·詹姆斯的死》一书中解释了她死前的岁月，罗伊·梅克皮斯带着一丝痛苦的声音说道：事情从糟糕变得不可收拾，最后走向死亡。我尽了一切努力去支持、安慰、同情她。她是一个性格内向的人，会把很多事情藏在心里。
Initially, Roy was of the belief that Cindy was targeted by an unknown perpetrator. However, as time went on, Cindy kept destroying the evidence of her attacks, such as the time she asked Roy to throw away the slashed pillow. He recalled a time he and Cindy had arrived at her house together to find two floodlights that were assembled two meters above the ground had been unscrewed and smashed to pieces on the concrete below. Roy suggested to Cindy that they save the broken glass for police to fingerprint, but she insisted the glass be disposed of immediately. Around the same time, she asked Roy if he thought she was losing her mind. Roy told the jury that he reassured Cindy she wasn't. In hindsight, he said he wished he had encouraged her to open up by asking, what makes you think that? Roy Makepeace clarified some other points that had baffled investigators during the years. The word Hombagosh that Cindy recalled being said to her in the van during an abduction was actually Humbagakle, a Zulu term that meant, farewell, take care.
起初，罗伊坚信辛迪是某个未知袭击者的目标。然而，随着时间的推移，辛迪不断销毁她遭到袭击的证据，比如有一次她让罗伊扔掉被割破的枕头。他回忆起有一次他和辛迪一起回到她家，发现两个安装在地面上方两米处的泛光灯被螺丝卸下，砸碎在下面的混凝土上。罗伊建议辛迪把碎玻璃留给警察提取指纹，但她坚持要立即处理掉碎玻璃。大约在同一时间，她问罗伊是否觉得她疯了。罗伊告诉陪审团，他向辛迪保证她没有疯。事后回想起来，他说他希望当时能鼓励她敞开心扉，问她是什么让你这么想的。罗伊·梅克皮斯澄清了一些多年来一直让调查人员感到困惑的其他疑点。辛迪回忆说，在绑架期间的面包车里有人对她说过Hombagosh这个词，实际上是Humbagakle，这是一个祖鲁语术语，意思是再见，保重。
He explained that his sister used it often in conversation with Cindy and others, and perhaps the unusual phrase had become lodged in her brain. Roy also recalled a time just before they were married when Cindy read him a letter from her mother. The letter was written in an aggressive tone. It lectured Cindy about her poor choice in marrying a divorced man. When Roy asked to look at the letter later, Cindy sheepishly told him that she had written it herself and thrown it out. Looking back, Roy wondered if this odd event was the beginning of Cindy's problems. Roy Makepeace believed that Cindy had multiple personality disorder, now known as dissociative identity disorder. He cited the trouble that Cindy had remembering events, the side of her personality that he described as childlike, and the trauma that Cindy had suffered in her life as pointing towards this diagnosis. Roy criticised the medical care that Cindy had been given over the years of the attacks.
他解释说，他的妹妹在与辛迪和其他人的交谈中经常使用这个词，也许这个不寻常的短语已经深深印在她的脑海里。罗伊还回忆起他们结婚前不久的一天，辛迪给他读了她母亲的一封信。这封信的语气充满攻击性。信中指责辛迪嫁给了一个离婚男子是不明智的选择。当罗伊后来要求看这封信时，辛迪羞怯地告诉他，这封信是她自己写的，而且已经扔掉了。回想起来，罗伊怀疑这个奇怪的事件是否就是辛迪所有麻烦的开始。罗伊·梅克皮斯认为辛迪患有多重人格障碍，现在被称为分离性身份障碍。他列举了辛迪记事困难的表现、他形容为孩子气的那部分人格，以及辛迪一生中遭受的创伤，这些都指向了这个诊断。罗伊批评了多年袭击期间给予辛迪的医疗护理。
There was no competent psychiatrist taking charge of her psychiatric treatment. I'm so resentful of the inadequacy of her psychiatric care. Nobody checked the facts of her life, and that is tragic. It cost her her life. Roy believed that Cindy's use of the black nylon stocking to strangle herself might have had symbolic meaning, stemming from possible sexual abuse as a child. Cindy's brother gave evidence at the inquest denying he had ever sexually assaulted Cindy. The phone messages to Roy Makepeace's answering machine were played. Richmond Constable Jerry Anderson believed it was the voice of Cindy James on the recordings. Others, including Roy Makepeace and Cindy's friends and family, believed that the messages were left by a male voice. Roy was at a loss to explain them. The Psycholinguistics Centre in New York analysed the messages.
没有称职的精神病学家负责她的精神科治疗。我对她精神科护理的不足感到非常愤慨。没有人去核实她生活中的事实，这是个悲剧。这夺去了她的生命。罗伊认为，辛迪用黑色尼龙长筒袜勒死自己的行为可能具有象征意义，源于她小时候可能遭受过的性虐待。辛迪的兄弟在死因研讯中作证，否认自己曾性侵过辛迪。播放了留给罗伊·梅克皮斯答录机的电话留言。里士满警员杰里·安德森认为录音中的声音是辛迪·詹姆斯的。其他人，包括罗伊·梅克皮斯以及辛迪的朋友和家人，则认为这些留言是由男性的声音留下的。罗伊对此感到不知所措。纽约心理语言学中心对这些留言进行了分析。
The report found obvious similarities in voice characteristics between the recordings and audio of Cindy James' voice taken from a police interview. However, it reiterated that a positive identification could not be made because of the apparent disguise of the voice and the shortness of the messages. The two men who approached Roy's door were never identified. However, the incident was believed to be unrelated to Cindy James. The second part of the inquest focused on the day of Cindy's disappearance. Richmond detectives walked through Cindy's last known movements. They argued that Cindy had appeared so jubilant prior to her death because she had formulated a carefully orchestrated plan of her suicide and was going to carry it out. She went to the Blundell Road Shopping Centre, purchased the bags of non-perishable foodstuffs and a birthday present for her friend's son. There was no receipt with the grocery bags.
报告发现，录音中的声音特征与从警方审讯录音中提取的辛迪·詹姆斯的声音之间存在明显的相似之处。然而，它重申，由于声音经过明显的伪装且留言时间很短，无法做出明确的鉴定。接近罗伊家门的两个男人从未被确认身份。然而，这一事件被认为与辛迪·詹姆斯无关。研讯的第二部分集中在辛迪失踪当天。里士满侦探重走了辛迪最后已知的活动轨迹。他们认为，辛迪在死前表现得如此兴高采烈，是因为她已经精心策划了一场自杀计划，并准备将其付诸实施。她去了布伦德尔路购物中心，购买了袋装不易变质的食品和给她朋友儿子的生日礼物。杂货袋里没有收据。
Detectives returned to the shop and ran the purchased items through the checkout. None of the records for the day of Cindy's disappearance matched the dollar value of the groceries in Cindy's car. To detectives, it seemed as though Cindy had also purchased a pair of stockings and other items and took them out of the bag before leaving the car park. Lying under the car, Cindy's bank card and ATM receipt appeared to have been placed there. They argued if it had been dropped in a struggle, the receipt would have separated from the card instead of being wrapped neatly around it. Following the detective's narrative, sometime after leaving the car park, Cindy consumed a large amount of florezapam and morphine tablets. She then had 20 minutes to get to the abandoned lot one and a half kilometres away before the drugs would have rendered her unconscious. It was clear she had consumed the florezapam orally as residue of the drug was found in her stomach.
侦探们回到商店，用收银台重新扫描了购买的物品。辛迪失踪当天的所有记录都与辛迪车内杂货的美元价值不符。在侦探看来，辛迪似乎还购买了一双长筒袜和其他物品，并在离开停车场前把它们从袋子里拿了出来。辛迪的银行卡和自动取款机收据躺在车底，似乎是故意放在那里的。他们辩称，如果是在搏斗中掉落的，收据应该会与卡片分离，而不是整齐地包裹在卡片外面。根据侦探的推测，离开停车场后不久，辛迪服用了大量的氟安定和吗啡片。然后，她有20分钟的时间走到1.5公里外的废弃空地，之后药物才会使她失去知觉。很明显，她是口服氟安定，因为在她的胃里发现了药物残留物。
To record the level found in her bloodstream, she would have had to have swallowed between 20 to 80 pills depending on the concentration. In addition, if Cindy also took the morphine orally, she would have had to have swallowed 18 tablets or 20 mils of a liquid preparation. It was assumed Cindy had taken the morphine orally as an intravenous injection would have rendered her incapacitated immediately. This was despite the fact that a puncture mark from a needle was found on her right inner elbow. It could not be explained how Cindy had either of these drugs in her possession. She was not prescribed florezapam or morphine. There were no missing drugs from the hospital where she worked. Detectives theorised that the puncture mark on her right arm was caused by Cindy as she took blood from herself to smear on the door of her car. However, Cindy was right-handed, meaning this would have been a difficult procedure for her to complete.
为了达到血液中检测到的水平，根据浓度不同，她必须吞下20到80片药丸。此外，如果辛迪也是口服吗啡，她必须吞下18片药丸或20毫升液体制剂。人们认为辛迪是口服吗啡的，因为静脉注射会立即使她丧失行为能力。尽管事实上在她的右手臂内侧发现了一个针头穿刺痕迹。目前无法解释辛迪是如何拥有这两种药物的。她并没有被开具氟安定或吗啡处方。她工作的医院也没有药物失踪。侦探们推测，她右手臂上的穿刺痕迹是辛迪自己抽血涂在车门上造成的。然而，辛迪是右撇子，这意味着这对她来说将是一个很难完成的过程。
Detectives found it a plausible explanation that Cindy walked to the abandoned lot, laid down her coat, hog-tied herself, and then lost consciousness, falling to her right side. This was evidenced by her blue coat found partially underneath her body. To show the jury it was possible, not-tying expert Robert Chisnell took the same length and make of stocking found around Cindy's body. He demonstrated how it was done, completing the complex-tying procedure in about three minutes. He said that the stocking, when found, was tied loosely enough around Cindy's wrists and ankles that it could be slipped on and off. The hitches in the knots were also consistent with the unconventional way Cindy knotted her shoelaces. Robert Chisnell believed that the knots in this case matched previous incidents with Cindy. He also tied a black nylon stocking around his own neck in the same fashion, remarking that it was tight enough for him to feel light-headed, but not so tight that he would black out.
侦探们发现了一个合乎情理的解释：辛迪走到那片废弃的空地，放下大衣，把自己绑成猪肉卷一样的捆绑姿势，然后失去知觉，向右侧倒下。这从她被发现部分压在身下的蓝色大衣可以看出。为了向陪审团证明这是可能的，绑绳专家罗伯特·奇斯内尔使用了在辛迪尸体周围发现的同等长度和品牌的长筒袜。他演示了如何操作，在大约三分钟内完成了复杂的捆绑过程。他说，这双长筒袜被发现时，绑在辛迪手腕和脚踝上的松紧程度刚好可以滑进滑出。结里的活扣也与辛迪系鞋带的非传统方式相吻合。罗伯特·奇斯内尔认为，本案中的结与辛迪以前的事件相符。他还以同样的方式在自己的脖子上系了一只黑色尼龙长筒袜，并评论说，这足够紧，能让他感到头晕目眩，但又没有紧到让他昏厥的程度。
Cindy's friends and family were outraged at this explanation, citing that there was no possible way that Cindy could have carried this out on her own. Surveillance on Cindy's home always resulted in the harassing phone calls and mails stopping. The few times that Cindy's friends or family had heard calls or seen people lurking around could not be explained. One detective accused them of covering up for her. Cindy's former psychiatrist was of the impression that Cindy suffered from borderline personality disorder and post-traumatic stress disorder stemming from unknown childhood trauma. However, he argued it was difficult to diagnose and build rapport with her because she was such a guarded and private person. Other diagnoses by psychiatrists who had examined Cindy over the years included anxiety, major depression, paranoid disorder, major affective disorder, psychotic delusions and suicidal ideation. An excerpt from Cindy's journal written from St Paul's psychiatric unit when she was receiving treatment three years prior to her death was read out.
辛迪的朋友和家人对这种解释感到愤怒，他们指出辛迪绝不可能独自完成这一切。对辛迪住所的监视总是能让骚扰电话和邮件停止。辛迪的朋友或家人听到电话或看到有人潜伏在周围的少数几次事件无法解释。一名侦探指责他们在为她掩盖真相。辛迪的前精神科医生印象中，辛迪患有边缘型人格障碍和由未知的童年创伤引起的创伤后应激障碍。然而，他辩称，由于她是一个防备心极强且极其注重隐私的人，因此很难对她进行诊断并与她建立融洽的关系。多年来检查过辛迪的精神科医生的其他诊断包括焦虑症、重度抑郁症、偏执狂、重度情感障碍、精神病性妄想和自杀意念。宣读了辛迪在死前三年接受治疗时从圣保罗精神病学病房写下的日记摘录。
I still feel suicide is my best option in an unbearable situation and as soon as I get out of here, I will carry out my plan. The majority of the public sympathized with Cindy, a woman who was let down in every way by systems that failed to protect her. Despite admissions to psychiatric units, she was repeatedly allowed to go home without receiving consistent treatment or diagnosis of her condition. If it was that the attacks were occurring to her, the police failed to catch a perpetrator who terrorized Cindy for more than seven years. One forensic psychiatrist who reviewed Cindy's extensive medical history and police files told the inquest, the tragedy is that with all these people involved, she wasn't saved. The inquest into the death of Cindy James was one of the most expensive and lengthy in British Columbia history. In the end, the jury failed to reach a conclusion as to whether Cindy had been murdered or had taken her own life.
我仍然觉得在无法忍受的处境下自杀是我最好的选择，一旦我离开这里，我就会执行我的计划。公众大多对辛迪报以同情，这是一个在各方面都被未能保护她的体制所辜负的女性。尽管曾多次入住精神病科病房，但她屡次被允许回家，却没有接受针对其病情的一致治疗或诊断。如果说袭击确实发生在她身上，警方却未能抓获那个恐吓辛迪七年多的凶手。一位审查了辛迪大量医疗记录和警方档案的法医精神病学家在研讯中表示，悲剧在于，尽管有这么多人参与其中，她却没有被拯救。对辛迪·詹姆斯死因的死因研讯是不列颠哥伦比亚省历史上最昂贵、历时最长的研讯之一。最终，陪审团未能就辛迪是被谋杀还是自杀得出结论。
They determined that Cindy James died as the result of an unknown event after one vote shifted the decision from suicide to undetermined. Some thought that another person or persons were involved in the attacks orchestrated by Cindy. Others proposed that Cindy knew much more about the identity of the perpetrator than she told authorities. One factor that was not argued by nearly all who knew Cindy was that if she had indeed carried out the attacks upon herself, she was not aware that she was doing so. The terror in her eyes, the very real emotion she portrayed during countless interviews, convinced nearly all involved that Cindy truly believed these attacks were occurring to her. This lady suffered very deeply from within or out, one forensic psychiatrist stated. He suggested that Cindy cast herself on a stage as the victim in a fantastic plot of her own creation, adding, she was in a living nightmare.
他们确定辛迪·詹姆斯的死是由未知事件导致的，此前一票之差将决定从自杀改为了未定。一些人认为，另一个人或多个人参与了由辛迪策划的袭击。另一些人则提出，辛迪对袭击者的身份的了解远比她告诉当局的要多。几乎所有认识辛迪的人都一致认为的一个因素是，如果她确实对她自己实施了袭击，她并不知道自己正在这样做。她眼中的恐惧，她在无数次采访中表现出的极其真实的情感，说服了几乎所有参与者，让他们相信辛迪真的坚信这些袭击正在发生在她身上。一位法医精神病学家指出，这位女士内心或外部承受着极其深刻的痛苦。他暗示辛迪把自己塑造成自己创造的一个奇异情节中的受害者，并补充说，她生活在一场活生生的噩梦中。
The coroner concluded, Cindy James was a victim, real or imagined, and lived in terror for an unknown period of time throughout her life. The Hack family was devastated by the finding, hoping that the jury would recommend the case be reopened. They vowed not to let their daughter's death go, determined to find her killer and bring them to justice. Sifting through the rubble of one of the fires that engulfed Cindy James' basement, authorities found a mauve coloured notebook. It was Cindy's journal. The hard cover was decorated with Cindy's favourite thing, blooms of coloured flowers. Cindy's sister Melanie had purchased the journal for her during her separation from Roy Makepeace. On the inside cover, Melanie had inscribed a note and quote by naturalist John Muir at Red.
验尸官总结道，辛迪·詹姆斯是一个受害者，无论真实还是想象，在她生命中的未知一段时间里都生活在恐惧之中。黑克一家对这一裁决感到痛不欲生，他们希望陪审团能建议重新审理此案。他们发誓绝不让女儿的死就这样过去，决心找到凶手并将他们绳之以法。在吞噬了辛迪·詹姆斯地下室的一场大火的废墟中搜寻时，当局发现了一个紫红色的笔记本。那是辛迪的日记。精装封面上装饰着辛迪最喜欢的东西——盛开的彩色花朵。辛迪的妹妹梅兰妮是在她与罗伊·梅克皮斯分居期间为她买这本笔记本的。在内页封面上，梅兰妮题写了一段自然主义者约翰·缪尔的话。
To my dear sweet sister Cindy, it is always sunrise somewhere, the dew is never all dried at once, a shower is forever falling, vapour is forever rising. I hope that you feel the wonder of nature as I do, may it make you feel intensely alive and full of joy, now and forever. Thank you for watching. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
致我亲爱的甜心妹妹辛迪，某个地方总是日出，露水从来不会同时干涸，阵雨永远在下，水汽永远在上升。我希望你能像我一样感受到大自然的神奇，愿它让你感到无比的充满生机和喜悦，从今以后直到永远。感谢收看。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。